Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff.
Nach einer kleinen Pause machen wir hier wieder ein bisschen weiter mit unserer Krisenbegleitung. Heute geht's wieder mal um den Krieg in der Ukraine und dazu begrüße ich selbstverständlich Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, ist nämlich jetzt schon äh wieder eine Weile her, dass wir uns hier zu dem Thema das letzte Mal äh gemeldet haben.
Zwischendurch gab's ein bisschen Brexit. Tatsächlich haben wir gesendet am 23. Juni.
Jetzt haben wir den 6. Dezember.
Nein, natürlich nicht, den 6. September haben wir ganz so lange haben wir es jetzt dann doch nicht äh warten lassen. Ja, mit anderen Worten, es ist so äh einige Zeit vergangen und zwischendurch dachte ich immer so, hm na ja.
Müsste mal wieder äh was äh erzählen, aber.
Na ja, äh ich denke, jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt auf jeden Fall gekommen nach gut, was haben wir jetzt? So zwei, zwei Monate, die vergangen sind.
Der Krieg tritt in eine interessante neue Phase ein.
Ja und äh ich denke, es ist erstmal angemessen.
So ein bisschen zurückblicken, was denn eigentlich bisher so passiert ist und das mündet ja dann auch schon mehr oder weniger in die aktuelle äh Situation.
Man kann natürlich erstmal auch schon mal konstatieren, dass sich äh die ganze Sache immer noch im,
genau in der Mitte des Pfades äh bewegt, den wir mal abgesteckt haben für die Zukunft mit unseren zwei äh Szenarien von einem halben Jahr fast
äh oder so äh als es darum ging, okay, entweder.
Es es wird lange dauern jedenfalls. Das war damals äh äh schon schon klar und ähm ja,
es wird zum Stillstand kommen und dann wird man sehen wer äh wie viel schafft halt dann vom Land zu halten oder nicht zu halten oder
zu erobern und da sind wir immer noch in der oder genau in der Phase sind wir halt jetzt das.
Das erstmal zum Stich, aber na zugleich, denke ich.
Ein bisschen mehr im Detail, aber aber es ist jedenfalls nichts. Es ist keine überraschende Wendung eingetreten. Putin ist noch ist noch am Ruder und irgendwie keiner Seite ist es jetzt gelungen irgendwie ja zu gewinnen, sage ich mal.
Genau, das auf jeden Fall.
Trotzdem die Dinge haben sich ein bisschen verändert. Also wo waren wir letzte Mal stehen geblieben? Wir hatten äh Ende Juni die Situation, dass,
Die Russen mächtig Druck gemacht haben im Donbass, vor allem nicht nur, aber vor allem,
in der Region um Civero Donetsk und Lucy Chansk das ist so eine.
Stadt, kann man sagen, die durch den Fluss geteilt ist. Also natürlich
technisch gesehen zwei verschiedene Städte, die aber eben sehr nah beieinander liegen. Luzid Chans liegt äh deutlich höher und eben hinter diesem Fluss, so dass das äh jetzt rein militärstrategisch.
Zwei verschiedene hm Aufgaben waren für die Russen. Letzten Endes haben sie aber so viel Druck gemacht, vor allem durch ihre übermächtige Artillerie in der Situation, dass äh der Ukrainer.
Letztlich nicht sehr viel übrig geblieben ist, als sich aus dieser Falle ein wenig zurückzuziehen. Ähm,
und das haben sie dann getan und seitdem ist in der Region nicht so sehr viel passiert. Zwar drücken die Russen da nach wie vor rein, haben aber eben nicht mehr so viele Kräfte vor Ort, dazu gleich mehr.
Und die Verteidigungslinien der Ukraine sind an der Stelle weitgehend äh stabil. Also das ist halt.
Vor allem die Region, um.
Gramators, was ohnehin so ein bisschen das Verteidigungszentrum der Ukraine äh schon immer gewesen ist im Krieg im, der ja jetzt nicht erst seit sechs Monaten läuft, sondern im Prinzip schon seit zwanzig 14.
Und ähm.
Von daher ist auch nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen, dass sich an dieser Situation dort bald sehr viel äh ändern wird.
Ähm obwohl der Druck halt der Russen dort noch stark ist, gelingt es mittlerweile der Ukraine nicht nur die Position zu halten, sondern an verschiedenen Stellen. Die Russen auch schon wieder ein bisschen zurückzudrücken.
Warum ist das so? Das hat vor allem damit zu tun, dass dass die Ukrainer vor.
Ein, zwei Monaten auch in zunehmenden Maße darüber angefangen hat zu reden, dass sie eine.
Offensive eine Gegenoffensive vorbereiten. Eine Gegenoffensive im einer südlichen Front, also auf die Stadt Rasson.
Das ist ja die äh Region, die die Russen zu Beginn sehr schnell haben einnehmen können, was sicherlich auch eine konkrete militärische Niederlage der Ukraine am Anfang
des Krieges wahr. Dort konnten die also von der Krim aus sehr schnell vorstoßen. Haben dann den äh den Fluss dort äh schnell.
Überwunden und äh dort eben ja ein Teil der südlichen Ukraine eingenommen, der äh.
Westlich dieses Flusses liegt, ne oder von der Flussströmung aus gesehen auf der rechten Seite.
Und äh während die Russen dann versucht haben über die Schlüsselstadt Nikolaiw äh in irgendeiner Form sich den Weg Richtung Odessa zu bahnen, konnten sie dort also gestoppt werden und.
Seit äh ja einem halben Jahr ist da die Frontlinie relativ stabil gewesen,
Ukraine konnte also mehrfach die Angriffe aus dann,
und das Ganze war so ein bisschen eingefroren. Man hat sich da auf einzelne Scharmützel ähm weil es bei einzelnen Scharmützeln.
Belassen und man wusste nicht so richtig, ob sich da noch irgendwas groß ähm tun wird. Aber durch die Ankündigung dieser Offensive.
Dann die Russen irgendwann kalte Füße bekommen.
Weil sie eben auf gar keinen Fall Herrsson hergeben wollen, weil das natürlich für sie nach wie vor eben der Brückenkopf sein könnte für einen weiteren Vorstoß in die Ukraine.
Und ähm haben dann angefangen Truppen zu verlagern aus dem Donbass.
In diese Region, über diesen Fluss äh hinweg, um dort ihre Verteidigungsstellung zu verstärken,
Ja, aber zu dieser ganzen Offensive kam's erst mal irgendwie nicht. Also es war
Generell so ein bisschen die Frage, warum erzählt überhaupt die Ukraine so viel dadrüber, weil letzten Endes in so einem Krieg, wenn man irgendwie eine Offensive startet, das Letzte, was man tut, ist halt irgendwie das anzukündigen.
Ah wir werden euch gleich da angreifen und ähm mittlerweile.
Zeigt sich, dass das wohl eine ganz interessante Kriegslist gewesen zu sein scheint.
In der Zwischenzeit hat sich die Ukraine vor allem nennenswert verstärkt. Einerseits durch westliche Waffentechnik.
Vor allem zu nennen das Heimaß äh Raketensystem, einmal es steht äh letztlich für eine.
Mobile Raketeneinheit, die einerseits sehr weit schießen kann, aber andererseits auch unfassbar ähm präzise ist.
Da kann man also Ziele wirklich auf den Meter genau treffen und eben bis zu 70 Kilometer überbrücken.
Das Ganze ist halt auf ähm ja Radfahrzeugen montiert und lässt sich sehr schnell in Stellung bringen und vor allem, nachdem man geschossen hat, auch sehr schnell wieder verstecken, sodass die Russen eben auch wenig Möglichkeiten haben
hier den,
der Raketen zu detektieren und auf einen bestimmten Abschlussort zurückzuführen in nennenswerter Zeit, sodass wenn sie also überhaupt in der Lage sind, den Abschussort zu detektieren.
Und dann in irgendeiner Form ihre Atelier Artillerie drauf äh lenken wollen, dass sie dann einfach überhaupt gar nicht genug Zeit haben, weil die sind dann schon wieder weg.
Gesehen davon, dass durch diese hohe Reichweite sich diese äh Fahrzeuge ohnehin vermutlich außerhalb der Reichweite der normalen russischen.
Artillerie befindet. Ja und damit haben die äh Ukrainer sowohl im.
Süden als auch im Osten dann doch erstaunliche Fortschritte erzielt, denn sie haben.
Primär Munitionsdepots, Command und Control.
Also wo halt in irgendeiner Form operativ der Krieg geplant wird, ja äh gesteuert wird.
Geleitet wird ähm und Tanklager und Ähnliches in.
Attacke genommen und das hat äh mit dem dazu geführt.
Die Russen gezwungen waren, ihre ganzen Munitionslager sehr viel weiter ins Hinterland zu verlegen.
Was natürlich,
bedeutet, also abgesehen von dem reinen Munitionsverlust, der natürlich durch die Zerstörung dieser Lager erfolgt, dass äh auch die ganze Logistik eben noch schwerer wird, weil das bedeutet, die ganze Artillerie
noch sehr viel längeren Wegen, auf ungesicherten
LKWs quer durchs Land gefahren werden. Das dauert lange, das hat nicht so eine hohe Kapazität und die sind natürlich auch deutlich weniger geschützt. Das heißt, auch,
lassen sich im Idealfall auch noch angreifen und damit kann man sagen, ist diese ganze Offensive im Donbass.
Zwar nicht zum Erliegen gekommen, aber die Anzahl der Artillerie äh Schüsse und die Anzahl der Vorstöße und konkreten Angriffe und vor allem natürlich auch dann die entsprechenden Fortschritte, die waren dann einfach deutlich abgesenkt.
Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass die Russen, während sie halt auf der einen Seite ihre ähm Staatstruppen dann in den Süden verlagert haben ähm vor allem diese
Privatarmeen, diese Wagner Group dort äh aktiv war, damit sie da irgendwie auch nicht so hohe Verluste erleiden.
Zumindest nicht Verluste erleiden an offiziellen Soldaten eben diesen Söldnern, die halt der russischen Öffentlichkeit dann im Zweifelsfall auch total egal ist.
Ja plus natürlich tragischerweise.
Halt auch die äh ja Ukrainer, die eingezogenen, äh die dann ja für die Neue irgendwie
äh äh Republik äh und so weiter äh dann äh kämpfen so.
Und oder kämpfen müssen, die dann äh ja hauptsächlich auch äh als ja kann man sagen, fast als Kanonenfutter oder Lücken äh äh Füller
miserabel ausgestattet, da auch reingeworfen wurden und extreme Verluste haben. Man geht davon aus, dass allein ungefähr zehntausend ähäh Soldaten.
Sagen die eigentlich aus der Ukraine stammen auf russischer Seite ums Leben gekommen sind.
Ja, das ist natürlich nochmal echt besonders bitter, also die Russen sind da einfach gnadenlos und äh ja versuchen vor allem
Soldaten quasi überall zu rekrutieren, bloß nicht ihre äh eigentliche Mobilmachung zu injizieren, weil das nach wie vor
für die Russen äh ein großes Problem wäre. Darüber haben wir ja auch schon gesprochen. Einerseits weil das eben die russische Öffentlichkeit auf einmal
äh aufwecken würde, damit wäre quasi diese Spezialoperation ja ein richtiger Krieg, damit würde sich die rechtliche Situation.
Ändern. Man würde halt äh also wenn wenn das eben halt so eine Mobilmachung tatsächlich aktiviert werden würde, auf einmal äh.
Ältere Leute aus den Betrieben rausholen, das würde die Wirtschaft nochmal weiter ähm hm bedrücken,
aber vor allem würde es sich halt eine Menge Geld kosten, ne.
Ja und äh noch auch ein Detailproblem daran ist, äh dass äh wenn denn so eine Mobilmachung so eine allgemeine
ausgerufen würde, dass
äh einen sehr hoher Anteil äh an äh Reservisten auch in den inneren Sicherheitsdiensten äh beschäftigt ist im Apparat, ne.
Und da gab es eben auch schon
Nachrichten, dass die halt so überhaupt gar keinen Bock haben plus das natürlich damit äh dann äh diejenigen Leute, die eigentlich im Inneren für Ruhe und Ordnung äh sorgen, dann plötzlich ein Großteil davon außerhalb des Landes wären.
Was dann auch noch Instabilität schafft und aber vor allen Dingen sind das halt Leute, ja ähm.
Die man eigentlich für auch für was anderes äh äh braucht und äh von denen wohl dann auch massenweise gesagt haben, nee, dann dann kündige ich lieber, das heißt,
äh dass es sozusagen auch noch mal einen ja ein unschönes Problem.
Wo Rücksicht, ich sage mal auf die alten Leute oder auf die Wirtschaft,
äh nimmt äh Putin ja gerade nicht so sehr, aber ich glaube, wenn's dann darum geht
quasi die die Ordnungstruppen, die inneren äh dann zu schwächen oder oder die gegen sich aufzubringen, das ist dann glaube ich ein bisschen,
Delikate.
Dann nahm aber die Sache auf einmal Fahrt auf, weil es passierte äh etwas extrem Unerwartetes.
Nämlich dass es auf einmal extrem gezielte und für die Russen desaströse Angriffe gab auf der Krim.
Die Krim ist ja bisher eigentlich vom Kriegsgeschehen noch überhaupt nicht tangiert gewesen.
Aber ähm auf einmal gab es eine mächtige Explosion auf einem der äh Militärflughäfen.
In ähm weiß ich gerade nicht mehr ganz genau, wie der Ort äh hieß, äh.
Novofedo RIFK war das glaube ich, genau und ja, dort gab's auf einmal riesige Explosionen.
Getroffen wurden zahlreiche Militärflugzeuge der Russen,
und äh getroffen wurde sozusagen auch die Volksseele, die paar Kilometer weiter am Strand ihren Urlaub verbrachte, die Krimis ja auch ein beliebtes Urlaubsziel für viele Russen.
Auf einmal sahen sich diese ganzen Touristen mit dem Krieg konfrontiert von dem sie ja bisher äh dachten, dass es ihnen vielleicht gar nicht gibt.
Ja und das war äh für die Russen ein echtes Problem.
Einerseits war natürlich da der Verlust an Material äh enorm war, aber das eben auch auch auf einmal die Russen in einem Bereich angreifbar und verletzlich waren, indem sie vielleicht selber so nicht äh gerechnet haben.
Die äh Touristen haben daraufhin in Scharen die Krim äh verlassen. Da gab's dann.
Interessante Videos von äh Leuten, die dann über diese Kehrbrücke, das diese neu gebaute Brücke zwischen äh Russland und der Krim.
Äh ja äh versucht haben, ihm die Krim zu verlassen und ähm.
Da gab's dann riesige Staus und das war irgendwie alles ein großes Drama, weil alle jetzt irgendwie Angst hatten jetzt. Brennt gleich die ganze Krim und dann will man dann vielleicht nicht unbedingt Urlaub machen.
Bis hin sogar dann äh dass die Brücke oder die Straßen dann teilweise für Privatverkehr dann auch gesperrt
äh wurden, weil man dann auch keine Truppentransporte oder Ähnliches oder Rücktransporte äh mehr möglich waren, weil
äh ja das war halt dann dann auch noch äh sagen so ein Ding und wann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht wollte, dass es so viele Leute jetzt abhauen.
Ja das äh war auf jeden Fall ein Schock und ähm diese.
Ganze Situation hat sich dann auch noch weiter zugespitzt. Es gab dann noch weitere Angriffe. Im Norden der Krim bei.
Ähm wo auch nochmal Militärlager
Munitionslager und auch Zugverbindungen angegriffen wurden und es blieb vor allem die ganze Zeit unklar, wie es den Ukrainer eigentlich gelungen ist, das zu machen
weil.
Der westlichen Waffentechnik hatte das wohl nix zu tun. Also soweit ich die Analysen richtig verstanden habe, waren das jetzt keine Haymas, Angriffe.
Sondern und ich weiß gar nicht, hast du da was gesehen, ob sich das in irgendeiner Form geklärt hat, weil es gab sowohl die Vermutung, dass es sich dabei,
entweder um neu entwickelte ukrainische Misshalts gehandelt haben könnte oder eben auch äh lokalere Angriffe von Special Forces, die,
in irgendeiner Form die Krim infiltriert haben und diese Angriffe koordiniert haben. Vielleicht war es auch eine Mischung aus beidem.
Dukkain hat sich auf jeden Fall offiziell dazu erstmal gar nicht geäußert.
Keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist, irgendwie, aber schön, dass da alles explodiert.
Die Russen ja immer noch offiziell äh dann immer behauptet haben, ja das wäre ja einfach nur Miss Handling auf nur Nischen gewesen und das hätte sich quasi alles selbst entzündet, aber die Story ließ sich ja eigentlich nicht wirklich halten.
Ja also in interessant ist es,
sowohl Ukrainer als auch Russen sozusagen öffentlich darüber schweigen, obwohl beide Seiten.
Ziemlich genau wissen, was da passiert äh ist äh aber es ist interessant, dass da noch nicht so richtig was äh immer noch nicht an die
Öffentlichkeit äh geraten ist. So worauf ich tippen würde, äh
wären halt Drohnenangriffe so, das es Drohnenangriffe waren, entweder mit Drohnen, die ja ähm,
sagen tatsächlich dann von Special Forces irgendwo gestartet äh wurden, also dann aus der Nähe quasi äh also,
nicht aus der Ukraine heraus, sondern aus der Nähe auf die Ziele äh äh gelenkt äh worden.
Und eine andere Theorie noch, womit äh sich das halt auch
noch des Schadensbild so ein bisschen erklären äh ließe, wären halt äh auch Raketen, äh die sozusagen die die großen Varianten ähm.
Von den äh ja Raketenwerfersystemen, die dann,
Nämlich ähm ja Submunition haben und sich dann äh äh verteilen äh und so.
Aber äh ja, also für mich sieht das sieht das am ehesten wie wie Drohnenangriffe aus und es war am ehesten konsistent mit den Fähigkeiten auch der.
Ja der Ukrainer und es wurde auch teilweise ja beobachtet äh ähm
bei Angriffen tief in in Russland äh wiederum jetzt nicht nicht auf der Krim äh wo dann Munitionslager mit ich sage mal Selbstmorddrohen angegriffen.
Wurden so das.
Das ist richtig.
Also was ist auch immer dann genau war? Es war so oder so ein klarer militärischer Erfolg für die Ukraine und hat eben
gesamte Logistikkette angegriffen und das war halt auch der Sinn der Sache. Ja und das leitet jetzt alles auf die aktuelle Situation,
ähm über.
Nämlich die dann tatsächlich eingeleitete Gegenoffensive, die dann äh von der Ukraine auch offiziell bestätigt wurde.
Sie haben generell äh gesagt, so wir werden da jetzt mal nicht so viel zu erzählen.
Aber äh auf dieser Frontlinie in,
äh Region, die jetzt mal nicht so äh kurz ist, also das sind so, was weiß ich, glaube ich, so 2fuffzig Kilometer Frontlinie, die äh von der wir hier äh sprechen.
Und äh vor einer Woche haben Angriffe mehr oder weniger auf der
vollständigen Länge dieser Frontlinie begonnen. Das heißt, äh auf einen Schlag
sind die äh Ukrainer an und da gibt's dann jetzt eine sehr
unterschiedliche äh Zählungen. Man könnte sagen, es gab so zwölf verschiedene,
Vorstoßbereiche, die sich vielleicht so grob in drei oder vier Schwerpunkte einteilen lassen, sowohl äh an den beiden äußersten Frontlinien als auch in der Mitte, glaube ich, lag so ein bisschen so ein Schwerpunkt.
Und ja, was bedeutet das jetzt? Hm erstmal die Situation nochmal.
Die Russen haben jetzt über einen längeren Zeitraum Truppen abgezogen in größerer Menge und über die Brücken.
Über diesen Fluss in diese Region gebracht und dort eben ihre Stellungen ausgebaut.
Dann haben aber die Ukrainer angefangen mit ihren Haimas-Raketen oder den amerikanischen Halmasraketen gezielt genau diese Brücken.
Äh anzugreifen und derer gibt es eigentlich nur,
zwei. Direkt bei der Stadt Rasson gibt's diese Antonowski äh Brücke. Das ist eine relativ große Brücke, lange Brücke, die eben über diesen sehr breiten Fluss führt,
und ein wenig äh flussaufwärts bei Nova Kachowka gibt es einen Staudamm.
Der natürlich etwas delikat zu bespielen ist, aber durch diese.
Hochpräzisions Raketen, es ist den Ukrainern gelungen eine kleine Brücke am Anfang dieses Staudamms wo also wo noch nicht wirklich gestaut wird, also wo nicht die Staumauer ist, sondern wo nochmal so ein.
Da läuft ein Kanal, genau, da läuft.
Kanal, der sozusagen dafür äh sorgt, dass eben da auch Schiffe durchfahren können, so eine so eine Schleusensituation.
Und diese Schleusenbrücke, die wurde also gezielt mehrfach angegriffen
jetzt vor ein zwei Tagen gab's auch äh erste Bilder, die zeigen, dass äh der eine Teil der Brücke, der da wo die eigentliche Straße ist
wohl komplett eingestürzt ist und der andere Teil, da wo die Bahnlinie verläuft, ist zumindest extrem äh beschädigt worden.
Worten über diese Brücke können keine Verstärkungen mehr eingefahren werden und genauso sieht es bei dieser großen Antonowski-Brücke aus
die zwar nicht komplett eingestürzt ist, aber die zumindest so massiv beschädigt wurde. Auch da gab's jetzt grade neue Bilder. Da sieht man also auch aus der Ferne schon eine erhebliche Zerstörung.
Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass beide Brücken einfach nicht mehr geeignet sind, schweres Gerät rüberzufahren. Sprich.
Eine Versorgung mit schweren Gerät ist nicht möglich. Russen haben dann versucht verschiedene Ponton-Brücken und Fähren aufzusetzen, die dann aber in der Folge auch
bombardiert wurden und man kann davon ausgehen, dass einfach die Fähigkeit der Russen in irgendeiner Form die Versorgung mit schwerem Gerät oder vielleicht auch nur mit äh anderen logistischen Material durchzuführen, dass die also.
Nachhaltig äh eingeschränkt wurde. Dazu kommt, dass auch noch eine dritte Brücke.
Ähm angegriffen wurde, die aber nicht über diesen geht, sondern das ist dieser ähm
Fluss. Das ist quasi so ein Myander, kleinerer Fluss.
Diesen ganzen russischen, also von den Russen äh eingenommenen Bereich so knapp in der Mitte teilt.
Der also auch nochmal ein nennenswertes Hindernis ähm für die Russen darstellt beim hin und her von Material und äh Truppen. Es gibt da zwar mehrere Brücken.
Aber wohl nur eine, die so richtig schwerlast-tauglich ist. Die anderen Brücken sind alle ziemlich altrostig, klein oder generell nur für
geringe Gewichte äh gedacht oder liegen dann wiederum so weit im Norden, dass das dann äh mindestens also einen riesigen Umweg äh darstellt, beziehungsweise das auch schon so in diese Gebiete kommt, wo eben jetzt die Ukraine reindrückt.
Sprich wir haben jetzt die Situation sehr viele Truppen im Land.
Keine weitere Versorgung aus dem Süden möglich, also nur über Flugzeuge, aber das bedeutet eben.
Einerseits, dass die natürlich gefährdet sind, beziehungsweise dass einfach die Kapazität äh nicht ansatzweise an das rankommt, was man jetzt mit großen Konvois erreichen kann und die sehen sich eben jetzt einem Angriff,
auf einer 250 Kilometer Front äh entgegen die.
Im Prinzip jetzt so gestaltet zu sein scheint, dass die Ukrainer überall angreifen.
Jetzt nicht versuchen, mit aller Macht.
So weit zu kommen wie es irgendwie geht, weil das würde dann erhebliche Verluste bedeuten, ne? Es gibt ja diese Einschätzung, dass wenn man angreift, dass man dann immer so das Dreifache an Material äh und Personal zum Einsatz bringen muss als die Verteidigende äh
Seite.
Ja und die USA und im inneren Städtekampf äh äh kalkulieren äh die USA immer mit zehnfacher Überlegenheit, um irgendwie Städte äh halbwegs ja äh sicher einnehmen zu können, ohne allzu viele Verluste.
Das haben ja die Russen dann in äh auch äh gehabt, das Problem, dass die Verluste da wohl extrem hoch waren.
Und das ist natürlich nichts, was die Ukraine möchte, sondern ich denke, es geht hier um etwas.
Anderes, also was ich zumindest so abzeichnet, ist die Strategie ist, man greift überall an.
Man ist in der Lage, die erste Verteidigungslinie oder ist, man war in der Lage wohl an vielen Stellen, wenn nicht allen die erste Verteidigungslinie zu.
Überlaufen, das jetzt nicht besonders verwunderlich, weil die erste Verteidigungslinie ist halt auch eine relativ dünne Linie, ja, also wo,
zwar Leute stationiert sind, aber wo eben jetzt nicht unbedingt das schwerste Gerät ist, sondern im Prinzip beobachtet wird und zurückgeschossen äh wird.
Wenn irgendwelche Vorstöße dort festgestellt werden, aber wenn man da eben massiv vorgeht, dann kann man die eben schnell überlaufen und dann.
Wird einfach geguckt, okay, wo sind denn jetzt hier wirklich die Widerstände?
Wo sind die Russen unter Umständen schlecht aufgestellt? Dort verstärkt man dann wiederum den Angriff, während man sich an anderen Bereichen,
zurückhält oder vielleicht auch nochmal zurückzieht, um die eigenen Verluste eben im Griff zu halten,
Russen sind sozusagen auf der gesamten Breite dieser Frontlinie
beschäftigt in irgendeiner Form der ganze Zeit drüber nachzudenken, wo droht denn uns jetzt wirklich am meisten Gefahr? Das heißt, sie müssen überall präsent sein und sie müssen natürlich dann auch, um verteidigen zu können
diese ganzen Standorte auch weiterhin mit Munition versorgen und äh mit allem anderen, was so,
Soldaten so brauchen versorgen. Ich meine, mit der Versorgung der russischen Truppen sieht's ohnehin nicht besonders gut aus, aber die Situation verbessert sich für die äh sicherlich an der Stelle überhaupt.
Durch die Trennung noch durch diesen Fluss in der Mitte und die entsprechenden unterbrochenen Brückenverbindungen wird es dann insbesondere für diesen östlichen Teil wohl extrem schwierig.
Sollte es jetzt den Ukrainern gelungen gelingen in irgendeiner Form einen Durchbruch,
vorzunehmen und diesen Bereich dann auch zu teilen, dann äh könnte es für die russischen Truppen so richtig bitter werden, weil die dann einfach am Ende keine andere Chance haben als sich zurückzuziehen.
Und das scheint mir so ein bisschen die Strategie zu sein, die sich jetzt hier abzeichnet. Das heißt, man greift an, man greift aber nicht.
Super massiv an, man beschäftigt die Russen und man trocknet sie im Prinzip aus.
Einfach nicht mehr in der Lage sind, jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form weitere Verstärkungen zu liefern und eben auch nicht diese Truppen zu
füttern oder eben auch nur mit Munition nennenswert zu versorgen, so dass das eben jetzt so ein Abnutzungskrieg ist, in dem vor allem die Ukraine die Offensive übernommen hat. Das ist nämlich jetzt sozusagen das Neue an der ganzen Situation
Bisher hatten wir Phase eins. Russland greift Kiew an, die Ukrainer müssen verteidigen. Das haben sie dann gewonnen. Phase zwei,
Russland greift im Donbass an und unter großen Verlusten
musste die Ukraine verteidigen, aber immer hat sozusagen Russland bestimmt, was jetzt das nächste Krisengebiet ist und jetzt hat sich der Spieß insofern umgedreht, als dass die Ukraine jetzt bestimmt,
wie sich Russland zu verhalten hat und ihnen eine Menge der Optionen sich zu verteidigen an der Stelle äh genommen zu haben scheint.
Sodass es eben durchaus sein kann, dass wir jetzt hier über einen Zeitraum von eins, zwei äh Monaten ähm,
Erfolge sehen können, die vielleicht nicht unmittelbar sich jetzt in großmessbarem Landgewinn niederschlägt.
Aber eben in so einem strategischen Gewinn, als das einerseits Russland seine ganzen Truppen dort geparkt hat, nicht mehr zurückführen kann ohne Weiteres.
Auch nicht verstärken kann und dass sie äh sozusagen in so einem Abnutzungs äh Krieg immer schwächer werden, was dann eben die Ukraine in zunehmenden Maße ausnutzen kann.
Glaube ist hilfreich, sich auch vor Augen äh zu führen, mhm,
wie lange die Russen gebraucht haben, um zum einen äh ja Marienpol äh.
Zweieinhalb Monate gedauert, am Ende äh die Gegend zu besetzen oder auch jetzt der Vormarsch dann.
Auf äh da und so, der da zum Stillstand gekommen ist, um um dort auf dem Donbass
voranzukommen ist zu dem Punkt ja fahren auch nochmal drei Monate.
Insofern kann man jetzt nicht erwarten, dass die Ukrainer jetzt in einer Art Blitzkrieg ja in drei Tagen plötzlich äh äh Kerlsong
befreien, zumal sie auch nicht so kämpfen können äh wie die Russen das getan haben, die ja mit massivem
Einsatz von ja dummer Munition alles plattgebombt haben. Das machen die Ukrainer in
so machen sie das das das auch. Die haben ja auch noch alte Munition, aber nicht so
in die Maße plus dass sie halt auch nicht so rücksichtslos gegenüber Zivilbevölkerung und der möglicherweise dann der Infrastruktur agieren, also
ja alles flächenmäßig in Schutt und Asche zu legen können Sie nicht und und wollen Sie nicht und
äh wollen natürlich auch nicht jetzt zu viele Leute verlieren, sodass wir schon richtig gesagt hattest.
Die Taktik jetzt eher ist. Die Russen mürbe zu machen, bis sie,
wesentlichen äh von alleine äh die Stellung äh räumen, so mehr oder weniger ja kampflos dann irgendwann oder.
Aber ähm ja insofern ein, zwei Monate, wenn es innerhalb von ein, zwei Monaten gelingen äh würde, jetzt wäre das natürlich ein ein äh unglaublicher Supererfolg, der auch so was wie eine die Wende.
Im äh Krieg bedeuten könnte erstmal.
Absolut. Also.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das gelingen wird in diesem Zeitraum, aber es macht grundsätzlich den Eindruck, als ob die Chancen der Ukraine hier den Russen äh einen starken Schlag zu verpassenden doch stark gestiegen sind.
Und es ist vor allem auch kaum.
Wie die Russen dieses Gebiet halten wollen. Also ohne Verstärkung wird das einfach nicht möglich sein.
Ne? Es ist ja ich meine es ist natürlich so ein bisschen, ich sage mal, gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit Styling-Grad von der taktischen äh Situation. Äh lang auch äh irgendwie dann äh auf,
Auf der anderen Seite äh ja eines eines Flussufers ein ein Brückenkopf äh,
zu verteidigen und ähm natürlich.
Können Sie, ich sage mal, schon die Truppen, ich sage mal, mit dem Allernötigsten wahrscheinlich schon versorgen. Ähm,
Allerdings äh ja nicht mit den Mengen an an Munition äh die sie gewohnt sind.
Normalerweise dort einzusetzen und die Optionen der Russen sind einmal halt mit Booten über den Fluss äh Sachen äh rüber zu bringen,
mit einzelnen und äh per Hubschrauber. So das sind so die wesentlichen Dinge und sie haben wohl auch Hubschrauberaktivitäten ausgeweitet, aber dass dadurch, dass sie
ukrainische Luftabwehr jetzt auch besser geworden ist man sind wohl auch schon,
der Hubschrauber jetzt in der Gegend in in letzter Zeit äh dann abgeschossen.
Worden. So und äh ja in insofern ja würde ich auch sagen
ist es nicht oder so. Es ist nicht nicht wirklich jetzt,
sagen hundertprozentig sicher, dass die dass die Russen äh das verlieren äh werden, aber,
ähm die Chancen sind dort auf jeden Fall für die Ukraine am besten äh äh gerade ähm ja taktisch gesehen einfach von der.
Geographie, um wenigstens dort die Russen rauszukriegen.
Nach einer Operation aus, die sie sich sowohl überlegt haben und diese langfristig vorbereitet haben,
und wo sie äh den richtigen Zeitpunkt abgewartet haben, bis sie halt auf der einen Seite stark genug sind, genug Waffen haben, um das auch äh durchzuhalten und zumindest nicht zurückgeschlagen zu werden. Die Russen da äh zu beschäftigen
Dadurch, dass sie halt auch weiterhin mit ihren Heimmaßsystemen eben diese ganzen Munitionsdepots ähm.
Ausfindig machen und äh zerstören und dabei sicherlich ja natürlich auch die Unterstützung der lokalen Bevölkerung haben, ne. Ich meine, ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass in jetzt alle konvertiert werden.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass sie auch eine ganze Menge Unterstützer haben aus der Zivilbevölkerung oder eben auch aus äh infiltrierten äh Special Forces, die also weiterhin
Standorte der Russen auskundschaften, dann entsprechend zurückmelden und dann äh relativ zielgerichtet dann auch vernichtet werden können.
Das ist halt einfach alles nicht schön. Also man äh hört einfach auch so äh aus den ganzen Kanälen
einfach die Truppenmoral dort einfach am Tiefpunkt ist
dass viele der Meinung sind, dass sie sich also jetzt hier komplett in der Falle befinden und ich meine, ich kenne jetzt keine also keiner kennt, glaube ich, genaue Zahlen, aber so schätzungsweise 20.000 ähm Truppen haben sie dort äh schon versammelt
Und das könnte natürlich dann auch ein riesiger
Verlust werden für die Russen, weil die können da halt nicht raus. Die können sozusagen nur in Booten über den Fluss äh sich retten oder versuchen zu schwimmen. Aber die können ja auch nicht so ohne Weiteres in in Massen äh zurückgehen.
Äh in dem Moment, wo die Ukraine soweit vorgedrungen ist und dann eben auch unmittelbaren Artillerie Zugriff hat auf die Flussregion.
Muss natürlich sagen.
Die Russen sind natürlich dann immer noch auf der anderen Seite des Flusses so und werden natürlich dort auch Artillerie.
Positionieren, das heißt sie werden schon auch in der Lage sein ähm
dort verhältnismäßig aus geschützten Positionen heraus zu agieren, aber ähm.
Auch das leidet natürlich unter der eingeschränkten Versorgung durch das Hinterland, weil natürlich.
All diese ganzen anderen Munitionsdepots in der Krim et cetera auch permanent bedroht sind.
Und dadurch, dass äh es den äh Ukrainern auch noch gelungen ist, die Zahl der Kriegsflugzeuge in diesem Gebiet auch noch äh massiv zu senken, kann es durchaus sein.
Äh sie in zunehmendem Maße die Lufthoheit ähm erobern können. Also es gibt auch Berichte, dass sie sehr viel dieser.
Einsetzen. Das sind sozusagen Anti-Rediation.
Also Raketen, die speziell darauf äh optimiert sind Radarsysteme zu detektieren und dann zu zerstören?
Das tun sie wohl auch in äh erfrischender Häufigkeit, sodass dann eben diese ganze Luftabwehr in dem Gebiet auch immer schlechter wird der Russen, das muss man,
sehen, wie sich das dann ähm zahlenmäßig dann ausdrückt, aber das Ganze kann dann eben äh auch bedeuten,
die Ukrainer auch zunehmenden Maße ihre eigene Airforce äh mehr zum Einsatz bringen kann und das ist natürlich dann gerade für das Halten der Stellung in diesem weiten, offenen, flachen Land äh sehr schwierig.
Ja. Noch ein Detail vielleicht zu diesem zu diesen Harmraketen, also zu diesen ja äh.
Oder Anti äh Radar äh Raketen ähm.
Die geraten so ein bisschen wieder aus der Mode.
Jetzt, also sind jetzt nicht so das des Zukunftsmodell, aber es gibt halt eine ganze Menge äh davon und ich denke mal gerade weil das sozusagen bisschen Auslaufmodelle äh äh sind
haben die Amerikaner dann auch kein großes Problem damit ähm.
Deren ja Vorräte äh dann dann zu liefern, weil der der Punkt ist und sagen ähm,
Die Dinger sind halt sauteuer, weil die quasi ja Radar such.
Und Empfänger und äh alles Mögliche in sich in sich vereinen.
Und ähm jetzt aber dann am Ende auch nicht unbedingt genauer äh sind als äh,
jetzt moderne Systeme, wo im Prinzip das Flugzeug.
Intelligenz hat, dass das das Flugzeug grade die Intelligenz hat, den den Ursprung ermittelt und dann.
Einfach eine Rakete, die sich an den Ort begibt, unabhängig davon, ob,
das Radar weiter strahlt oder nicht, sondern man peilt es quasi einmal an und schickt dann halt so eine ja äh Rakete, die dann halt äh nach
PS und Initialen Navigation einfach hinfliegt, das ist billiger, das ist das ist Standard, die kann man halt universeller einsetzen gegen alle Ziele und deswegen geht halt mehr der
der Trend eben in die Richtung und wieder weg äh von von Hahn, aber für die Ukrainer ist das natürlich super, ähm weil äh die.
Haben diese Harmraketen auch äh irgendwie an die die Mix äh rangedrahtet haben dann zwar nicht alle Features, aber ähm.
Ja äh gibt's dann wohl so drei, vier verschiedene Missionstypen, äh äh die man damit fliegen kann und ähm.
Äh entweder man fliegt äh rum und wartet, dass irgendwo was angeht und äh schießt das dann dann ab oder,
so und also das Ding ist, dass die halt diese Raketen müssen halt vorher muss man ihnen auch sagen, welche Art von Radarsignatur sie denn jetzt bekämpfen äh äh sollen so.
Was sie halt wohl dann nicht können ist dann in Echtzeit. Ah hier ist jetzt 'ne neue Bedrohung, hier laden wir jetzt das Profil runter aus den,
und greifen dann an, sondern was die Ukraine halt machen müssen, dann ist, dass sie das halt vorher auskundschaften, dass ungefähr wissen, okay, da ist
und dann stellen sie die Rakete, bevor sie losfliegen auf diese Signatur der äh des Radars
äh äh ein, dass sie angreifen wollen und fliegen dann und warten dann, dass das Radar angeht und greifen dann halt äh quasi das Vorbestimmte. Da hatten so ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen.
So oder so hat aber auch diese Offensive jetzt eine kritische Zeit.
Für die Ukraine und das hat damit zu tun, dass wir uns natürlich jetzt langsam dem Herbst nähern.
Und dann ist damit zu rechnen in diesem Gebiet, dass dann die Zahl der Regenfälle doch äh deutlich zunimmt,
Und das ist in dieser Region aus mehreren Gründen problematisch für beide Parteien in gewisser Hinsicht. Einerseits ähm.
Hat das was mit der Beschaffenheit des Bodens zu tun. Das ist wohl eine extrem schlammiger Boden,
Der also wenn er nass ist, so extrem saugfähigkeit äh entwickelt, sodass wenn's da mal ordentlich geregnet hat, man mitm Panzer einfach nicht mehr übers Feld fahren kann.
Wie das jetzt vielleicht gerade noch möglich ist. Ähm das heißt dann.
Kann man im Prinzip nur noch auf den befestigten Wegen fahren, von denen es jetzt gar nicht äh so viel gibt. Diese ganze Region ist eine
einzige Agrarwüste, kann man sagen, also nicht Wüste, weil's trocken ist, sondern weil's da einfach fast nichts anderes gibt. Es gibt.
Immer mal wieder ein paar Siedlungen und dazwischen einfach riesige Felder. Und dadurch, dass das einfach so einen.
Feuchtgebiet ist, ne? Einerseits hast du halt diesen großen äh Fluss und dann eben die Regenfälle, die äh Fluss. Das ist alles sehr fruchtbar, deswegen wächst da ja auch so viel, deswegen ist das auch die Kornkammer Europas.
Ähm aber äh um das alles überhaupt Landwirtschaftlich urba,
zu machen sind dort eben sehr viele Drainage-Kanäle gezogen worden
Das heißt, diese ganzen Begrenzungen, die man auch sieht. Man hat kennt das ja auch aus vielen Videos, was dann immer so diese langen, geraden Streifen, wo so ein paar Bäume äh sind, wo sich dann immer die Panzer drin versteck
äh zwischendurch dann eben auch entsprechende Feldwege. Ähm.
Das sind dann teilweise eben auch richtige äh Drainagekanäle, die eben sehr breit sind. Also die was weiß ich, so sechs Meter breit und auch ziemlich tief sind und da kannst du dann halt auch mit einem Panzer nicht so ohne Weiteres durch.
Also da kommen sozusagen zwei Dinge zusammen. Erstmal die generelle Beschaffenheit ohnehin schon plus eben noch diese ganze Schlammsaison und jegliche
äh Offensive, die wirklich mit schwerem Gerät geführt werden soll, wird dann eben für beide Seiten irgendwann im November dann auch,
schwierig bis unmöglich werden und dann kommt natürlich der Winter, dann wird's eh nochmal furchtbar kalt,
dann mag das zwar alles einfrieren aber dann kann man eben auch keine Gräben mehr ziehen et cetera sprich das gilt dann auch für den Dornbass. Alles was.
Bis zum Wintereinbruch nicht geschafft ist, das wird dann wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger so bleiben, bis dann äh im Februar, März äh sich diese Situation wieder äh etwas entspannen kann.
Von daher sind jetzt eben beide Parteien eigentlich drauf und dran.
Bis zu dieser potenziellen Selbstverstärkungsphase äh natürlich auch,
Fortschritte zu machen und das ist natürlich schon wiederum eine eine Stoppuhr, die den Ukrainern hier im im Nacken sitzt, weil es wäre natürlich.
Riesen Erfolg, wie du schon gesagt hast, wenn sie in irgendeiner Form in diesem Gebiet bis dahin diese Oberhand gewinnen äh können, weil das würde der ja dann auch bedeuten, dass sie.
Erhebliche Truppen dort abziehen können, weil halt einfach den Fluss zu sichern dann relativ einfach ist, gerade mit den zwei zerstörten.
Brücken, da haben einfach die Russen dann überhaupt hätten dann die Russen sozusagen keine Chance mehr in irgendeiner Form vorzustoßen und man könnte das ganze Truppenkontingent, was derzeit dort im Einsatz ist, wieder äh auf die andere Seite der Ukraine bringen
sowohl eben die Fronten um äh im Norden oder im Nordosten,
äh Situation im Donbass um und äh du nettst dort zu verstärken gegen Angriffe zu führen
aber vor allem
um, sollte man jetzt mal das so positiv denken, dass es ihnen also wirklich jetzt gelungen sein sollte, Herssoren dann zu befreien oder zumindest soweit in Griff zu kriegen, dass da nicht mehr so viel Truppeneinsatz nötig ist. Dann,
es eben auch durchaus vorstellbar, dass die Ukraine ihre Gegenoffensive weiter nach Osten zieht.
Äh im Gebiet um also das ist sozusagen.
Aufm halben Weg zwischen und dem Donbass, da wo dann äh,
der Fluss nicht mehr im Weg ist, weil die Ukraine dann von Norden einfach vorstoßen könnte, dort eine weitere äh Offensive zu starten und dann eben vielleicht die Russen sogar bis zu Krim oder darüber hinaus zurückzudrücken.
Mein, die das wahrscheinlichste Muster.
Was wir sehen werden, wenn sie erfolgreich sind ist wahrscheinlich erstmal.
Eine Folge von kleineren
Erfolgen, also kleineres Vorrücken, vielleicht hier und da einen einen Durchbruch an manchen Stellen, aber dass dann, wenn es denn dann kommt, innerhalb von ja wenigen Tagen
sich die Russen dann,
ja ausm Staub machen werden irgendwann so wie ja äh der Rückzug rund um um Kiew ungefähr gelaufen.
Ist so, dass dass äh.
Ja äh wäre zu vermuten, wobei sie dort noch eine ganze Menge äh schweres Material wieder mitnehmen konnten, um Kiew und das äh wäre dann wohl äh eher ein
nicht der der Fall äh da unten, das kriegen Sie dann nicht mehr raus. Die Leute können's könnten Sie äh noch größtenteils halt rauskriegen, glaube ich.
Die Leute schonen, aber dann würde eben viel Gerät entweder zerstört werden oder eben sogar auch direkt in die Hände äh der Ukrainer fallen und dann äh entsprechend dann auch noch ihren Militärbestand verstärken.
Aber am schlimmsten wäre natürlich die psychologischen Auswirkungen natürlich äh so.
Auf Russland dann, weil das ja.
Das wäre eine Niederlage, ja.
Interessant äh genau, was dann in Russland passiert und ähm was ich auch gehört habe, ist, dass es da wohl gerade politisch so ein bisschen zu köcheln äh äh scheint. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch noch.
Thema haben, aber.
Äh ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast, der sich vor zwei Tagen irgendwie mit einem merkwürdigen Video an die Öffentlichkeit gewandt hat.
Ist jetzt wer.
Der tschetschenische äh äh Republik Gouverneurer, der da.
So der der Vlogger, der sich als so.
Genau Dorn, der immer irgendwie nach jedem äh fast jeden zweiten Satz mit dem Wort Don beendet, wenn er äh äh
wenn er äh redet und der meinte halt jetzt ja, er sei ja irgendwie jetzt der,
am längsten regierende Gouverneur und so und äh
jetzt langsam mal eine Pause verdient und äh ja, äh würde jetzt mal irgendwie eine Auszeit vom Regieren nehmen demnächst. So.
Was alle äh glaube ich ziemlich überrascht hat und ähm äh es gibt irgendwie jetzt zwei
äh äh verschiedene Mutmaßungen, was denn dahinter stecken äh könnte.
Entweder äh dass er vielleicht irgendwie vorbereitet dann irgendeine Position in Moskau anzunehmen, das oder
äh das Umgekehrte, dass er mit dem Ganzen nichts mehr zu tun haben möchte und sich gerne irgendwie dass das eine Absetzbewegung ist, weil er gehört ja eigentlich zu einer von der einer von Putins treuesten Schergen äh bisher,
äh gewesen und ähm also das hat äh sehr viele verwundert und äh ja,
und gibt wohl viele so so Zeichen, dass das gerade so in in Russland die Unruhe äh im Apparat äh beginnt.
Ja zu steigen.
Das haben wir natürlich schon oft gehört so, dass äh würde ich immer mit äh Zurückhaltung
äh registrieren, aber diese äh äh Truppen, also der Typ ist ja wirklich äh wirklich äh eine eine Show, ne. Also,
die sich äh sozusagen an diesem Krieg beteiligt haben, ohne sich an diesem Krieg zu beteiligen, ne? Weil immer, wenn du die siehst, so, das sind dann immer so äh die Jungs.
Eigentlich erst irgendwo reinmarschieren, wenn die anderen schon alles abgeräumt haben. Also sie haben immer saubere Uniformen und man sieht auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht, dass die in irgendeiner Form kriegsmüde äh sind, ja.
Machen dann die ganze Zeit diese Videos, wobei in letzter Zeit sind wohl diese Videos auch sehr selten geworden, weil wie vermutet wird dann doch wohl äh einige aus dieser Truppe äh
ablebig geworden sind und vielleicht äh hat er nicht mehr genug Leute um sich herum um noch Spaß zu haben.
Ja, ja. Ja, plus das ist ja ursprünglicher Putin irgendwie Bataillone versprochen hat
zigtausend von tschetschenischen Kämpfern und so und wohl nicht wirklich viel geliefert hat. Der hat die zweimal wie groß aufmarschieren lassen zu Hause so aufm Platz, aber
in die Ukraine äh Istanbul nicht so richtig viel gekommen, insofern könnte es auch sein, dass
Putin irgendwie äh so ein bisschen äh ja auch keinen Bock äh mehr auf ihn hat. Man weiß es nicht. Man wird sehen.
Ja überhaupt ist es so mit den ganzen Allianzen der der Russen so eine Sache, ne? Also China
unterstützt die Russen eigentlich auch nicht direkt ja sondern die sind eher so opportunistisch unterwegs und versuchen sozusagen,
äh überall sich einen Vorteil zu sichern, wo die Russen schwach werden. Aber was ja auch sehr interessant ist in dem Zusammenhang, ist die gesamte
politische Konstellation mit den einstmals so verbündeten anderen Staaten äh allen voran äh.
Generell gibt's in diesen ganzen ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken sehr viel Zurückhaltung, einfach dadurch, weil.
Sie befürchten, dass Putin diese Ukrainedoktrin, die er da gerade äh vertritt letzten Endes auch auf sie wieder anwenden könnte
Ne, so nach dem Motto, ja ihr wart ja schon immer Teil Russlands und hier großrussisches Reich und das Ganze ist ja ohnehin eine extrem
rassistisch geprägte Kampagne und da dreht sich so ein bisschen der Wind und die ganzen
äh Lenker insbesondere eben in sind so sehr zurückhaltend geworden bis hin, dass sie eben auch aktiv sagen, sie würden eben Donbass Republiken et cetera äh nicht anerkennen und auch nicht die Ukraine
ja und versuchen letzten Endes jetzt mehr äh sich China zuzuwenden und das kann natürlich Putin auch nicht recht sein.
Ne und äh ich meine China, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast, hat jetzt auch das ihr Union Pay für Russland gesperrt.
Genau, mhm.
Vor zwei Tagen irgendwie äh immer hieß, na ja, die Russen werden halt,
irgendwie für Kreditkarten dann äh für Karten irgendwie.
Ja auch
stärker auf das chinesische Union Pay setzen und äh Chinesen äh so zeigen ihnen jetzt einfach den großen Finger
ähm so, weil einfach keinen Bock auf sekundär Sanktionen haben plus
dass die Russen halt auch für die Chinesen nicht kreditwürdig sind. Ja, das vergessen halt auch viele, dass die Chinesen also was für die Chinesen vielleicht
auch äh äh ja immer wichtig ist, ist Geld und äh offensichtlich in diesem Sinne äh,
da da ist eher Geld zu verlieren als zu verdienen und äh Reputationsschaden und so, deswegen also hier in diesen.
Machen gerade ja interessante Absetzbewegungen von von Russland.
Also das ist.
In etwa die Zusammenfassung der militärischen Slash politischen Lage, ist natürlich.
Noch sehr viel vielfältiger und wir könnten jetzt hier noch.
Stundenlang über verschiedenste Details hm diskutieren, aber ich denke, das ist so das, was man jetzt erstmal.
Verinnerlichen sollte, dass eigentlich die Gesamtsituation ist zwar schwierig, aber nicht hoffnungslos.
Ukraine ist relativ gut aufgestellt und ähm im Rahmen ihrer aktuellen Möglichkeiten ziemlich,
erfolgreich. Die Russen haben einfach nicht mehr ähm die Initiative in diesem Krieg und das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Aspekt, denn,
Wer die Initiative hat, der bestimmt, wo's äh wo's lang geht. Die Russen sind derzeit nicht in der Lage in irgendeiner Form äh eine weitere Bedrohung darzustellen, abgesehen natürlich von.
Raketenangriffen im Hinterladen, Zerstörung von ziviler Infrastruktur. Natürlich sind äh die unmittelbar jetzt an der Frontlinie und in den besetzten Gebieten ähm gelegenen Ortschaften und Dörfer natürlich.
Zerstört und äh,
dort äh dürfte es ähm auch gerade in den in den besetzten Gebieten selber sehr viel Leid geben, Verschleppung, äh was nicht alles.
Klar, aber davon ausgehend, dass das eben so der Status quo ist, sind die Russen derzeit nicht in der Lage, signifikantes Leid noch weiter zu vergrößern.
War jetzt gerade ja auch in der Ukraine die Schule begonnen hat so und.
Auch gehört habe, ist, dass die Russen jetzt in die besetzten Gebiete zuverlässige Lehrer geschickt haben.
Die dann äh jetzt den Kindern in der Schule einbläuen sollen, dass sie irgendwie Russen sind und dass es keine Ukraine gibt und so.
Ähm und äh ja also auch nicht so der Hit äh für die Kids in den besetzten Gebieten, ja.
Eine Situation, eine Spezialsituation sollte man vielleicht noch mal kurz äh tangieren und das ist die Situation.
An dem Kernkraftwerk äh dem Saborischa Kernkraftwerk bei das ist am
Südufer des Teils, äh wo der so fast schon seheartig äh groß ist und dort
ist eben dieses Kernkraftwerk mit sechs Reaktoren das größte Kernkraftwerk Europas und das kam natürlich in den letzten Wochen auch nochmal zu trauriger Berühmtheit, weil äh einerseits die Russen
seit langer Zeit besetzt haben, aber eben selber auch als,
Militärbasis nutzen, das heißt, sie positionieren dort ihre Artillerie und ähm greifen damit verschiedene Ziele,
zivile Ziele vor allem in der Ukraine im Norden an, aber natürlich.
Die Ukrainer dort nicht so zurückschlagen, wie sie's sonst tun würden, weil sie dann natürlich äh quasi die Gefahr laufen würden, dass Kernkraftwerk in irgendeiner Form zu zerstören.
Reaktoren selber sind wohl so noch nicht getroffen worden, aber sehr viele äh der unterstützenden äh Technik drumherum. Ja und,
Kühlungssysteme et cetera, haben also schon äh Schaden genommen.
Ja plus die Stromtrasten und Anbindungen, die Werse sind zerstört worden, ja.
Zerstört worden, vor allem auch bewusst manipuliert worden, weil die Russen natürlich diesen Strom vor allem in den Süden nach äh in die Krim äh ableiten wollten.
Und verhindern wollen, dass eben weitere Stromflüsse äh in die Ukraine gehen, um also dort einfach das Land auch nochmal zu ähm
unter Druck zu setzen. Ähm die aktuelle Situation ist äh die, dass dann erstmal die IA, also diese internationale äh Atomenergiebehörde, ähm.
Hochgradig alarmiert war, dort eine Truppe hingeschickt hat äh und die sich die Situation angeschaut haben. Da sind wohl auch zwei jetzt noch zurückgeblieben, um die Situation weiter zu monituren.
Aber mittlerweile sind durch verschiedene Vorfälle alle Reaktoren abgeschaltet worden, bis auf einen, also da läuft jetzt nur noch der Reaktor,
Nummer sechs und der läuft auch nur, um sozusagen das Kraftwerk selbst mit Strom zu versorgen. Weil das wäre dann sozusagen.
Das wäre dann sozusagen wirklich äh der Punkt, wo es dann wirklich knifflig wird, weil wenn das äh Kraftwerk nicht selber mit Strom versorgt wird, dann kann sich halt nicht äh kühlen und dann.
Dann ist äh will ich sagen gleich Kernschmelzer angesagt, aber das kann dann auf jeden Fall zu äh einem erheblichen Störfall führen.
Insofern halten die Russen dieses Kraftwerk eben wirklich da als eine Geisel, weil's einfach militärisch sehr schwierig ist dort äh vorzugehen. Noch
ist dieser diese Region für die Ukrainer eben nicht wirklich
angreifbar, außer aus der Ferne und das eben auch nur sehr eingeschränkt. Ähm dazu müsste dann eben weiter östlich,
nochmal na so fünfzig Kilometer äh.
Größerer Durchbruch äh gelingen, aber das ist eben derzeit durch die Konzentration auf die Region,
Im Westen äh so überhaupt nicht darstellbar, aber könnte eben dann in der Zukunft vielleicht noch stattfinden.
Sollten wir vielleicht mal zu der Energie äh Krise kommen, die.
Der Rest von Europa jetzt zu erleiden hat, weil ja die Russen immer mehr das Gas einschränken und Deutschland.
Und andere Länder, Italien vor allem und Österreich äh darum bangen überhaupt noch ausreichend,
zu haben, um ihren Energiebedarf für Zivilbevölkerung und Industrie äh gedeckt zu bekommen.
Ja Thema Gas, äh so was uns ja gerade in Deutschland besonders umtreibt.
Unserer Abhängigkeit und da ging ja jetzt äh so in der letzten Woche die Abschaltung von äh äh Nordstream,
eins äh spektakulär durch die Presse und ist auch immer noch.
Aktuelles Tagesthema und ähm.
Ja äh ich hatte mich dann so ein bisschen darüber aufgeregt, äh dass die Russen irgendwie vorgeben, ja technische Schwierigkeiten und irgendwie
Öl
was da aus einer Turbine irgendwie raustropft auf äh des des dass da Feuergefahr besteht und es ist sozusagen aus technischen Gründen erstmal abschalten mussten was halt ziemlicher Bullshit
ist, weil ich habe mir immer angeguckt ähm was.
Ist denn da in dieser Kompressorstation eigentlich installiert und es gibt halt dort,
acht Turbinen ja die parallel laufen können plus vier weitere in Reserve ja und ähm.
Das sagen auch die Leute von Siemens, die das Ding gebaut haben, äh.
Ja, also das Ding kann betrieben werden, ja und so ein bisschen so ein so ein so ein Öleck kann man einfach vor Ort sogar mit Bordmitteln abdichten und das ist jetzt nicht so, ist jetzt eigentlich überhaupt kein Thema.
Ähm und ähm so aber wenn man dann jetzt mal äh äh,
da es gibt halt äh ja heutzutage im Internet kann man ja ähm sagen den den Fluss, durch die Pipelines quasi in Echtzeit oder täglich
zumindest ja sogar teilweise in in in Echtzeit über den Tagesverlauf äh monitoren äh öffentlich, wie viel durch welche Pipeline
gerade kommt und da kann man sehen, dass wir aber immer noch äh russisches Gas beziehen.
So und zwar über.
Über den Übergang über die Ukraine also auf der Zunge zergehen lassen ja,
die Russen schicken immer noch,
Gas zu uns durch die Ukraine, ja, wo man sagt, hm, Moment mal, äh wo wir ja denken, als erstes wird man irgendwie alles kappen, aber nee, nee, also das Gas über die Ukraine äh fließt halt noch weiter.
Und auch über Tox Stream äh kommt auch noch Russisches Gas äh äh zu uns, ja. Nur Nordstream ist halt ähm.
Ziemlich äh runter, also die,
Haben halt hatten halt erstmal meinen Nordstream eins besteht eben ja auch aus zwei Röhren. Einmal irgendwie äh eine, die nennt sich äh Fluxes, Nord Stream Fluxes und Nordstream Opal sind so die beiden.
Von Nordstream eins und da hatten sie eben erst die Luxus äh äh Pipeline den Fluss äh dort auf einen ich sage mal trickle äh,
ähm reduziert äh und auch äh ja äh und und Opal und äh dann.
Ja äh vor ein paar Tagen äh haben sie halt beide äh komplett
abgeschaltet. Also da fließt jetzt gerade null über über äh Nordstream und zu den Mengen, also vorher im August, kann man sagen,
war die äh Gesamtmenge aus Russland.
Ein Drittel dessen gefallen, was so im März noch geflossen ist pro pro Tag.
Und jetzt ohne Nord Stream ist es so, ein Viertel bis ein Fünftel äh dessen, was wir
quasi beziehen könnten aus Russland maximal, das heißt wir sind jetzt irgendwo auf fünfzehn bis zwanzig Prozent,
runter. Aber äh dass die Russen jetzt so lügen über über Nordstream,
sagt mir, äh dass sie möglicherweise vorhaben oder sich die Option einfach gerade offen halten wollen, äh einfach wieder äh Gas zu schicken.
Und äh einfach wieder ja Nord Stream hochzufahren, sagen einfach, ja wir haben's jetzt repariert und äh ja äh,
läuft wieder, so. Ähm und.
Dem räume ich so eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit äh ein, dass sie früher oder später das das Ganze tun werden oder tun werden müssen, äh falls sie nicht äh äh große, große,
Schäden vermeiden wollen.
In Kauf nehmen wollen, hm.
Äh äh ER für ihn Kauf nehmen äh wollen.
Leiden wollen. Genau, weil.
Erleiden wollen, ja.
Kann die nicht einfach so an- und abschalten, so, ne?
Ja und speziell bei sibirischen
Pipelines und im Winter. So kommen noch weitere Probleme äh dazu, die sowohl für
Gas und für Öl äh äh Pipelines zutreffen, aber dazu
nochmal nochmal später extra, vielleicht nochmal äh äh zu den sozusagen zu den Gasflüssen und was das was das jetzt bedeutet, äh vielleicht nochmal äh zu Ende machen und äh.
Wir beziehen ja jetzt nicht nur Gas aus äh Russland, sondern zum Höhepunkt, weil es ungefähr, ich sage mal, größenordnungsmäßig die Hälfte, das heißt wir haben schon immer ähm,
die die Hälfte äh des Gases von woanders herbekommen und hm,
im Wesentlichen ja Norwegen äh ist halt, beziehungsweise äh
gibt es dann unter ja Nordsee sind die Nordsee Pipelines äh so aus England äh kommt auch noch England hat halt auch durchaus nennenswerte äh Gasfelder
aber vor allem hat sich jetzt der LNG-Zufluss, also flüssig Gas-Importe über Tanker.
Nach Europa ähm quasi verdoppelt gegen,
über letzten Jahr. So und tatsächlich macht jetzt, was die Zuflüsse aktuell äh nach Europa
angeht
LNG jetzt der der größte äh Teil mehr als aus der Nordsee kommt, aber LNG und Nordsee äh äh Pipeline äh so,
machen jetzt ja äh dass das Gross unserer ähm Gasimporte in die in die EU,
geradeaus.
Und es gibt ja dann auch die Perspektive, dass tatsächlich Ende dieses Jahres Habeck sagt äh könnte im Dezember schon losgehen und gucken. Ist eine sehr ambitioniertes äh Ziel äh zwei neue LNG-Terminals in Deutschland, die ersten beiden überhaupt äh in.
Gehen könnten.
Denn das hat er ja schon vor einiger Zeit äh gestartet. Also da fanden sie sehr schnell durchmarschiert und gesagt, so jetzt äh müssen wir hier mal schnell.
Schnell mal was bauen und es wird halt ein neues LNG äh Terminal in äh Williams.
Hafen äh gebaut.
Also da gibt es ja schon einen großen äh Tiefseehafen, der schon vor längerer Zeit gebaut wurde, immer so ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen unternutzt äh war aus meiner äh Perspektive. Da kommt also jetzt noch ein LNG-Terminal äh dazu und ein zweites bei Brunsbüttel, also einer Mündung der Elbe.
Wird auch fleißig da angebaut und das wird wohl wirklich mit Hochdruck ähm.
Betrieben und ja, könnte dazu führen, dass hier die Gasversorgung bald.
Auch über diesen Weg dazukommt. Ist mich so ein bisschen überrascht hat ist, ich meine Terminal bauen und äh Schiffe anlegen lassen, das ist so das eine ähm.
Aber muss ja dann auch entsprechende Gas-Pipels haben, um das Gas dann eben auch wirklich ins Netz zu bekommen, aber das scheint wohl nicht so das Problem zu sein.
Ja, nee, also diese Pipelines transportieren ja unglaubliche ähm.
Unglaubliche Mengen, also äh ja teilweise äh.
Die Durchfluss äh Mengen auf den Grafen ja in Gigawatt äh angegeben
und äh ja so eine so eine Pipeline ähm so eine von den Nordstream äh Pipelines kann so glaube ich ungefähr vierzig,
äh äh Leistung, also entspricht sozusagen einer 40 Gigawatt ähäh Hochspannungs,
Leitung äh und die sind typischerweise so zwischen ein und 2 Gigawatt ausgelegt. Also sozusagen eine Pipeline äh entspricht ja 20 Hochspannungsleitungen, ja so ungefähr.
Von der Energiemenge, die da durchfließt. 20 bis 30, je nachdem. Und äh ja,
Deshalb also da sehe ich weniger das Problem äh sagen im Gegensatz zum Strom, wo wir Transportkapazitätsknappheit haben, speziell nach Bayern äh äh rein äh trifft es halt fürs.
Fürs Gas äh nicht so zu, aber der, wie gesagt, der eigentliche.
Zu dem zu dem Speicher oder ein Speicherthema äh kommen. Äh also vorgestern hat die EU ähm ja.
Noch irgendwie 4740 Gigawattstunden eingespeichert in die Gasspeicher,
189 entnommen. Ähm kann ja es gibt Tabellen, nur ganz für jedes Land
und für jeden Speicher in jedem Land kannst du halt genau gucken, wie viel da drin ist, wie viel da äh am Tag rein und rausgegangen ist und wie viel man da maximal rein und.
Äh äh rausspeichern kann und äh tatsächlich die die die Speicher haben Europa hat,
Speicher, wo man so 11.600 Gigawattstunden pro Tag einspeichern kann. Das ist sozusagen das Maximum, was man da reinpumpen kann und wie gesagt, viertausendsiebenhundertvierzig, also
sagen ungefähr ja äh fünfunddreißig Prozent
oder so dreißig Prozent irgendwas in der Gegend speichern wir gerade ein pro Tag dessen, was wir maximal pro Tag einspeichern könnten.
In Europa und selbst wenn die Russen jetzt das Gas komplett abdrehen würden, also auch das, was aus der Ukraine und über die Türkei äh kommt. Mhm,
werden wir immer noch äh in der in der Lage äh äh weiter einzuspeichern, ja. Zwar äh dann,
weniger, aber äh,
Ja, also aktuell äh kommen aus Russland irgendwo, ich sage mal, von den wahrscheinlich fünf-, sechshundert von den viertausendsiebenhundertvierzig.
Gigawattstunden pro Tag, die wir die wir hier
speichern. Ja, also die mit anderen Worten, die Abhängigkeit grade von den russischen Gasflüssen
ist nicht so groß, wie man das angesichts ehemals 50 Prozent oder so vermuten.
Würde das vielleicht der erste Punkt und andere wichtige.
Erkenntnis fand ich noch ähm gibt jetzt die ganzen Ländervergleiche, wie welches Land,
jetzt grade wie viel eigentlich eingespeichert solle gucken, dann muss er sich auf die Deutschen oder die österreichischen äh,
einspeicher äh Raten und aber.
Das ist halt alles etwas äh ja ähm missleading ähm also,
weil erstens ist es nicht so, dass nur weil das,
sich der Gasspeicher in einem bestimmten Land befindet, äh dass sich darin befindliche Gas
auch äh dem Land gehört, ja? Das ist der der eine Punkt ähm und dann sind so auch absolute Füllstände
sagen halt auch relativ wenig aus, also Österreich beispielsweise hat ein relativ niedrigen Füllstand
extrem viel Speicher im Vergleich zum Verbrauch. Das heißt äh österreichischen Gasspeicher werden überwiegend vom Ausland genutzt. Ja äh weil wenn Österreich seine Speicher vollmachen würde
dann könnte es zwei Jahre lang nur sich aus den Speichern versorgen.
Äh deswegen sind die Speicher aber im Moment in Österreich,
auch äh ja eher äh noch geringer gefüllt, wobei die füllen sich jetzt auch gerade stark, aber die sind halt bei 68 Prozent beispielsweise, ja also gehören.
Eher zu den äh zu den Nachzüglern beim beim Speicherfüllen und.
Es ist natürlich auch zu erwarten, wenn irgendwo das Gas knapp werden wird, dann wird es in Europa.
Werden, sage ich mal, äh sprich ähm,
man wird also zwischen den Ländern natürlich ausgleichen, wenn irgendwo in einem Land das Licht auszugehen droht, dann wird natürlich äh sagen, wird man da aus anderen Ländern einfach Gas hinpumpen oder Strom rein
äh leiten, ja, deswegen,
muss man eigentlich äh sagen Europa energetisch als Ganzes betrachten und es bringt relativ wenig jetzt auf die einzelnen Länder zu gucken, wie viel die jetzt äh äh grade eingespeichert haben oder wie lange die sich jetzt,
versorgen können, sondern am Ende wird's irgendwo einen Durchschnitt werden und wenn man jetzt den Prognosen.
Glaubt und die sind halt auch einigermaßen plausibel. Dann äh ja wird es knapp werden, wenn wenn Russland jetzt äh komplett abschaltet und hängt so ein bisschen daran, wie hart der Winter wird
aber ich sehe es eher verhalten optimistisch, gerade wenn ich auf die Zahlen gucke plus das jetzt aktuell zum Beispiel auch die deutsche Industrie.
19Prozent weniger Gas verbraucht als im Vorjahr. Ähm
ja äh plus mit äh ich sage mal alle haben sich jetzt schon drauf eingestellt einfach Gas zu sparen habe ich das Gefühl der Kombination aus Sparen und Ausgleich und LNG.
Substitution, äh ja wird's natürlich nicht schön werden jetzt auch für die für die Wirtschaft, aber,
allein aufgrund des hohen Preises hat sich der Verbrauch auch reduziert, weil so manche Dinge einfach sich nicht lohnen oder man jetzt gerade nicht nicht macht in der in der Industrie ja nicht nur um Geld zu sparen, sondern weil einfach bestimmte
Energie intensive Produktion gerade defizitär äh wäre das führt dann auch natürlich zu entsprechenden
Einspar-Effekt.
Einspareffekten aber in dem Moment natürlich auch äh Produktionseinschränkungen. Ne, also das ist ja eigentlich das, was man nicht unbedingt haben will.
Ja. Genau. Das ist natürlich ein ein echtes Problem.
Aber ich denke, immerhin führt es dazu, dass eben sowohl die Unternehmen, als auch die Privatverbraucher sich jetzt auch mal darüber Gedanken machen, wie man eben Gas auch wirklich einsparen.
So, ne und ähm schwer zu sagen bei wie vielen Leuten diese Botschaft schon angekommen ist, aber hohe Preise sind natürlich definitiv immer ein ein Weckruf, der gut funktionieren kann.
Ähm ihr habt zum Beispiel.
Meiner Wohnung leider so eine Gasetagenheizung, das ist jetzt nun wirklich die äh unangenehmste ähm Heizform von allen so und habe dann zumindest mal bei den.
Bädern, irgendwie das heiße Wasser abgedreht, einfach um.
Verhindern, dass man einfach unnötig in irgendeiner Form diesen Apparat äh anwirft. Auf Industrieebene denke ich mal, gibt's einfach Einsparpotential durch entsprechende Umrüstungsmaßnahmen.
Und ähm ja langfristig wird es natürlich jetzt auch Prozesse in Gang setzen.
Ähm besonders kritische Industrien, wie zum Beispiel Stahlindustrie äh hier einfach auf komplett andere Energieformen umzurüsten.
Jahr teilweise uns andere Länder schon vormachen.
Ja, ja. Ja und meinen anderer Punkt jetzt, wenn man diesen.
Gaskrieg oder wie auch immer man das bezeichnet, wobei Russland äh ja bestreitet irgendwie.
Einen Gaskrieg zu führen, sondern das sind halt nur leider technische Probleme aufgrund eurer Sanktionen, so ist ja die offizielle Variante. Ähm ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz äh es ist halt klar, dass es so eine Art.
Gaskrieg ist, äh der da äh geführt wird, aber äh Russland schießt sich damit einfach massiv selbst in den Fuß, weil äh.
Ja, Russland sich quasi in einer Zwickmühle äh befindet an der Stelle. So und zwar.
Wenn Sie uns jetzt das Gas abdrehen, was Sie offensichtlich tun, zwar nicht ganz bisher und
wie gesagt, vielleicht ja äh schalten sie's ja einfach wieder ein und tun so, als wäre nix gewesen. Ähm aber wenn sie das jetzt durchziehen, wovon Habeck im Moment auch ausgeht, wie gesagt, ich,
halt ich gebe Räume, dem eine gewisse Chance ein, dass sie halt plötzlich Nordstream wieder anstellen und alle irgendwie hä, was ist jetzt los?
Ja aber wenn sie es jetzt durchziehen gibt's eigentlich nur zwei.
Szenarien oder oder sozusagen zwischen spielt sich alles dann zwischen zwei Szenarien äh irgendwo ab dazwischen oder an einem der Extreme und zwar,
Ja
Das erste Szenario, was ich für das Wahrscheinliche halte, so der Westen und die Welt nehmen wir halt nur moderaten, wirtschaftlichen Schaden. Also ja, wir verlieren ein paar Prozent äh so kleine Rezessionen.
Aber ähm ja äh wir kommen da.
Halbwegs mitm mitm blauen äh Auge äh davon und ähm,
Ja, äh Russland hat dann in dem Fall nur seine Gaseinnahmen.
Verloren, ja? Die dann aber teilweise durch die hohen Preise wieder kompensiert werden, aber es ist dann halt nur einfach die die Gaseinnahmen sind weg. So Szenario 2 aber ist,
Sie haben Erfolg quasi mit ihrem Gaskrieg und fügen uns schweren wirtschaftlichen Schaden zu und die europäische Wirtschaft fällt in eine tiefe Rezession
Dann kann man davon ausgehen, wird sehr wahrscheinlich eine Weltwirtschaftskrise folgen,
so und ähm Weltwirtschaftskrise hat, wie der Name wahrscheinlich schon sagt
Auswirkungen auf die ganze Welt, also auch auf China beispielsweise und was natürlich auch in jener Weltwirtschaftskrise zu
sehen war, immer wenn die Wirtschaft erlahmt. Das haben wir damals irgendwie 2tausend7 in der Finanzkrise gesehen und ähm.
Dann bei bei Covid in dem Moment, wo die Wirtschaft sich verlangsamt oder abkühlt, geht halt der Ölpreis in den Keller.
Oder generell Energiepreise nehmen ab, weil natürlich hier wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit äh äh runtergeht so,
Tass würde also dann äh Russland doppelt treffen. Nicht nur hätten sie dann jetzt.
Ja niedrigere.
Einnahmen, weil sie kein Gas mehr exportieren, äh sondern der Ölpreis äh würde halt wieder entsprechend in den Keller fallen und das Gas ist ja eigentlich für Russland,
eher so ein Nebengeschäft, aber ein signifikantes Nebengeschäft, vor allen Dingen war's halt immer ein sicherer und relativ gut kalkulierbarer Einnahmestrom, nicht so sehr Schwankungen unterworfen wie der Ölpreis, deswegen.
Halt auch völlig irrsinnig dieses Geschäft jetzt aufs Spiel zu setzen, ja? Ist halt irgendwie so ein so ein so ein ja Ding.
Was ihr einfach permanent sicheres Geld in die Kasse schaufelt und äh ja. Aber ähm nichtsdestotrotz ist es halt nur ein ein Bruchteil, vielleicht
ja was zehn, 20 Prozent in der Größenordnung der Öleinnahmen, ja, sind die Gaseinnahmen. Das heißt, die Öleinnahmen sind das eigentliche, äh wo der russische Staat sich rausfinanziert.
Und.
Wenn die unter 50 Dollar äh äh fallen für Russland äh was halt so 70 Dollar allgemeiner Ölpreis bedeutet, weil die Russen schon im Moment zwischen 10 und 20 Dollar äh äh.
Rabatt geben müssen äh auf ihr Öl, weil es sonst ihnen keiner abnimmt.
So, weil da natürlich die guten Freunde Indien und China äh äh gerade äh dann äh ja
äh natürlich Russland dann nicht den vollen Preis für den normalen Preis zahlen kann man sich dann auch an der Ölbörse angucken. So
anderen Worten fällt halt der Ölpreis irgendwo der der was man so,
normalerweise als Ölpreis kennt allgemein äh sich WTI oder brennt oder so. Ähm fällt der unter 70 Dollar ungefähr, dann fallen die Russen unter 50 Dollar und dann,
äh können Sie keine Gewinne mehr aus dem Ölgeschäft
ziehen. Was halt nicht heißt, dass sie nicht noch trotzdem Einnahmen haben, aber die Einnahmen reichen dann nicht aus, um die Infrastruktur zu erhalten und die
Leute äh zu bezahlen. Das heißt, sie würden dann die Förderinfrastruktur auf Verschleiß fahren, ja? Ab dem Moment
was zwar auch eine Weile geht, aber auf jeden Fall hm
ist da äh ja wäre das halt quasi der der doppelte Schuss, also gleich
beide Rohre der Schrotflinte irgendwie oder oder in in beide Beine geschossen, ja? So äh wenn äh Russland Erfolg mit dem mit dem Gaskrieg äh hat und weil die Russen.
Nicht nicht so dumm sind, wie man manchmal glaubt, wenn man so von außen guckt, was sie was sie tun. So ist mein Gefühl, äh dass sie das äh sehr gut wissen, dass sie halt äh ja und deswegen
da mit dem Gas eben keine kein eindeutigen Cut gemacht haben, weil sie eigentlich,
des Fürchten, dass sie Erfolg haben mit dem mit dem Gaskrieg. So.
Aber jetzt auch nicht einfach nichts tun können so. Dann denken ja dass wir dann denken, dass die Angst davor hätten, also irgendwo, deswegen diese diese Laviererei. Ja,
und ein anderer Grund noch diskutierend äh äh wurde, ist, hm,
dass wenn Russland jetzt die Förderung einstellt oder massiv zurück.
Pferd, dass das zu Schäden an der Infrastruktur führt. Man kann die nicht einfach an- und ausschalten und,
gibt mehrere Gründe dafür, aber ein Grund, hm.
Dem ja auch erst vor Kurzem klar geworden ist, ist der aber völlig völlig eingängig ist. Äh gerade in Sibirien natürlich ist es kalt und,
so Pipelines, insbesondere Öl-Pipes frieren quasi ein, beziehungsweise das Öl friert nicht wirklich, sondern wird,
im Prinzip zu Teer, zu so einer Teermasse, wenn wenn das zu kalt wird und lässt sich dann nicht mehr pumpen. Ist die Leitung dicht und.
Normalerweise äh es gibt halt deswegen,
Heizungen, so im Prinzip ist an fast jeder Pumpstation äh ist dann auch noch mal, sind dann paar Kilometer Heizdraht um die Pipeline verlegt und da wird dann, weiß ich nicht, wann dann ein paar Megawatt
an Heizleistung äh reingepumpt, entweder elektrisch aus dem Stromnetz oder manchmal wird dann teilweise äh ja.
Auch äh mit ja gut mit dem Öl kann man's eher nicht so beim Gas kann man die Pipelines auch noch mit äh äh selber durch verbrennen ein eines Teil des Kases äh heizen aber der Punkt ist wohl.
Wenn so eine Öl-Pipeline grade, wenn die einmal fest ist, gibt es,
keine gute Methode, die wieder freizumachen, wenn das Zeugs da drin erstmal hart geworden.
Ist. Vielleicht könnte man da Methoden erfinden, weiß ich nicht. Äh ähm aber es scheint im Moment so zu sein, dass es billiger ist, dann eine neue Pipeline daneben zu legen, als so eine eingefrorene
äh Öl-Pipeline oder korgulierte Ölpipeline irgendwie,
den den den Teer da rauszukratzen, sage ich mal. Ähm oder weiß ich nicht ähm wahrscheinlich,
dann Methoden, wenn's nötig
wäre mit irgendwie irgendeinen Roboter, der sich dann da durchbohrt und einen Heizdraht hinter sich herzieht, könnte ich mir vorstellen, aber äh so ja äh aber eigentlich äh will man das nicht. Und wir haben ja auch und bei Gas.
Eben auch so, dass ich dann bei niedrigen Temperaturen, Hydrate bilden, die dann den Rohrquerschnitt reduzieren, so dass
äh die ganze Berechnung, die ganzen Durchflussberechnungen nicht mehr stimmen plus, dass sich halt,
Eis, um die Sensoren herum bildet, die dann zum Beispiel den Druck ermitteln und so. Das heißt.
Da entgleitet dir plötzlich die Kontrolle über die die den Betriebszustand der Pipeline, weil du keine verlässlichen Messwerte.
Ja als Plus. Das dann eben ja bestimmte Ventile oder Verteileinrichtungen oder Ähnliches äh so da.
Äh oder äh speziell bei bei dort an Stellen, wo dann Druckminderung oder so stattfindet,
ähm ja die Dinger dann auch einfach zufrieren und äh dann sind's auch nicht nur die Pipelines, sondern vor allem auch die Fördereinrichtungen, also sprich die eigentlichen Quellen und da wo es wo es halt rauskommt.
Und wenn man die einmal abriegelt, dann äh ja, kann's eben auch sein. Wie gesagt, das Zeugs friert zu und du musst eigentlich ein neu bohren.
Dann so und.
Das äh ja werden dann halt zusätzliche äh Kosten plus mein, was die Russen ja deswegen tun, ist äh dass sie dann am Ende der der Pipeline gerade Öl ab.
Nein Gas abfackeln im Moment, um das alles auch so ein bisschen in Bewegung.
Zu halten, aber die Mengen äh sind da nicht sehr groß, aber es kosten natürlich trotzdem auch Geld, so eine Pipeline.
In Betrieb zu halten und ähm ich sage mal Öl äh oder oder Gas aus Sibirien.
An äh die europäische Grenze zu pumpen, um es da abzufackeln, ist jetzt auch nicht äh äh gerade so toll, obwohl,
ausgerechnet, dass das.
Wahrscheinlich eher in der Größenordnung von äh ein paar Millionen pro Tag kostet das vielleicht höchstens 20 oder 30
äh äh Millionen, das heißt äh also der Betrieb der der Pipeline oder auch noch noch nicht mal ähm,
sodass äh im im Vergleich zum Wert des Gases, was halt nicht verkauft wird, das ist das ist dann der der größte Schaden oder der Wert.
Öls. Also sie könnten sie auch sagen wahrscheinlich sich leisten, sie weiter zu betreiben um das am Ende zu verbrennen, aber ja.
Schlau ist das nicht. So schlau ist das nicht und dann.
Wahrscheinlich gibt's auch wenig Erfahrung dann mit solchen Betriebszuständen oder äh weil ist wahrscheinlich noch nie vorgekommen.
Teilweise das dann über so lange Zeit Durchflüsse oder Abflüsse dermaßen reduziert worden. Das heißt, keiner kann wahrscheinlich auch so richtig sagen.
Wie schlimm das am Ende wird für die Infrastruktur und ähm.
Also ich habe das Argument äh noch gelesen, das kann ich aber jetzt nicht qualifizieren. Vielleicht kannst du das ähm.
Wird's ja kalt so auch äh in Russland, das heißt auch dort dürfte der Gasbedarf ja äh steigen und wenn sie quasi.
Den Output ihrer Pipelines dann in den Eigenverbrauch lenken und nicht ähm ihre eigenen Speicher füllen, dann könnten sie ja einen Teil dieses Druckes auch abnehmen.
Die Frage ist, ob das ausreicht, ob das irgendwie mit den Mengen, die sie äh fördern und äh normalerweise nach Europa äh schicken, in irgendeiner Form vergleichbar ist und ob das überhaupt technisch auch machbar ist.
Tja hm also ich würde das halt stark bezweifeln, äh dass irgendwie Russland.
In der Lage ist, irgendwie solche Mengen an Gas oder Energie.
Nur halbwegs sinnvoll in in irgendetwas Sinnvolles umzuwandeln. Als werfen dann jetzt Bitcoin-Farmen äh äh an oder so.
Sinnvoll muss es ja nicht sein, ja? Es muss ja sozusagen nur ihre Pipelines am Leben erhalten.
Ja, ja. Also.
Ja äh ich ich denke, es wäre managbar, ja. Also ist nicht zwangsläufig, dass äh die jetzt alle einfrieren ähm aber äh das ist halt eine delikate Geschichte.
Ja äh solche äh äh Betriebsänderungen. Das, was mit äh keiner weiß so genau, es gibt,
glaube ich wenig Erfahrung und die Tatsache, dass jetzt dann auch noch die ganzen ausländischen Experten weg sind, die halt einen Großteil des Betriebs natürlich übernommen,
haben so und der Wartung übernommen haben macht
das äh sozusagen so eine, ich nenn's mal Sonderbewirtschaftung des Pipeline-Systems nicht gerade einfacher, weil das ist nicht,
Es ist nicht trivial, he? Das ist nicht wie so eine Wasserleitung, die du äh an und auf drehst, sondern ähm ja
will halt schon vernünftig betrieben sein und äh da gibt's gibt's viel bewegliche Teile, viel was kaputt gehen kann und,
Ich sehe da sagt hohes hohes Risiko und.
Schwierig, also wird wird auf jeden Fall eine echte Herausforderung äh für Russland seine seine Infrastruktur da.
Dazu managen. So, ja aber finanziell.
Sind die Einnahmeverluste eigentlich des des Grass. Plus die Abschreibung, also das ist dann,
das Gas plus die die Pipelines werden ja auch älter, wenn sie da, selbst wenn sie nicht betrieben werden, ja äh nimmt ja die Lebensdauer ab und die Abschreibungskosten.
Sind sind halt auch nochmal das, was was richtig ins Geld geht, also höher als die Betriebskosten jährlich.
Das Ganze wirft er jetzt auch noch mal so einen Blick auf die Sanktionen, die jetzt über Russland äh verhängt wurden und das hm.
So langsam in den Zeitraum, wo alle damit rechnen, dass die Sanktionen auch Wirkung zeigen.
Kurzfristig ist das halt jetzt durch die hm erhöhten Einnahmen, durch die erhöhten Energiepreise äh etwas äh kompensiert worden, aber
wo äh Russland mit all dem Geld ja auch nichts anfangen kann, ist beim Einkauf von Hochtechnologie. Bin mir sicher, dass der Schmuggel und illegale Importbereich äh enorm floriert
so, aber ob das auch nur ansatzweise das kompensieren kann, was halt äh vorher an Technologieflow
nach Russland gegangen ist, das äh darf man dann doch wohl bezweifeln. Das betrifft.
Zwei Bereiche, denke ich mal, vor allem. Einerseits halt, um noch mal kurz bei der Energie zu bleiben. Die ganze Wartung.
Aber vor allem auch die Weiterentwicklung, technische Weiterentwicklung,
Äh all dieser ganzen Pipelines und Förderanlagen ist eben auch zum großen Teil von europäischen Know-How und äh europäischen oder internationaler Technik.
Elektronik et cetera ähm abhängig, ja? Nicht ohne Grund waren ja Shell und viele andere dann
Energieunternehmen in Russland dort aktiv und die haben sich nun alle zurückgezogen und damit geht natürlich eine ganze Menge Wissen und eine ganze Menge Fähigkeiten und eine ganze Menge Ressourcen raus. Das heißt
für die Russen auch schwierig dieses ganze äh diese ganze Energieinfrastruktur, die Produktionsinfrastruktur
auch nur ansatzweise weiter zu betreiben, geschweige denn in irgendeiner Form zu managen und auszubauen.
Siemens war beispielsweise auch sehr aktiv in Russland im gesamten Energiesystem und auch ja bei den Turbinen unserer Siemens hatte überall seine Finger drin und die haben sich meines Wissens auch komplett zurückgezogen.
Mhm, genau.
Aus Russland.
Und äh der andere Bereich ist natürlich vor allem die ganze äh Elektronik und das macht's ihnen natürlich jetzt auch schwer ähm Waffentechnik,
nachzuproduzieren, also verschiedenste Systeme stehen schon so im Verdacht äh.
Sozusagen nicht mehr verfügbar zu sein, also Cruise Miss Highs et cetera, ferngelegte äh Raketen und auch diese ominösen.
Äh Raketen, die auch arschteuer äh sind und eben einen extrem hohen Elektronikbedarf haben. Das kann Russland alles gar nicht mehr bauen. Die haben schon Probleme jetzt in irgendeiner Form Panzer noch nachzuproduzieren.
Das wird sich natürlich jetzt äh auswirken.
Ist, glaube ich, in Russland irgendwie um 75 Prozent runtergegangen, weil sie eben auch hier einfach die ganzen Komponenten nicht mehr bekommen. Da haben wir ja schon die europäischen Automobile äh Herstellerprobleme an alles ranzukommen, aber in Russland fällt das einfach jetzt,
komplett aus und das wird natürlich auch nicht unbedingt dazu beitragen,
dass sie diesen Krieg besser führen können. Also jetzt einfach, was die konkrete Pro-Es betrifft, überhaupt erstmal Gerät äh wieder ins Land zu bekommen oder die Ausfälle, äh die real sind, auch nur ansatzweise zu kompensieren.
Verschiedene Schätzungen. Keiner weiß das so ganz genau, was Russland bisher an Material tatsächlich eingesetzt hat, aber ich denke man kann äh schon davon ausgehen.
Bei dem.
Hohen Feuerrate, die sie ähm zum Einsatz gebracht haben, sowohl ihre Munitionsdepot schon extrem gelehrt sein dürften. Ich habe so Schätzungen von 35 Prozent ihrer
Artillerie Munitionsbestände
ähm gelesen. Das ist natürlich jetzt alles ankonform. Das sind alles nur nur nur Schätzungen und Hochrechnungen und keiner weiß das genau und ich glaube, das weiß noch nicht mal Russland ganz genau. Aber es ist definitiv so, dass sie halt in zunehmendem Maße auf altes Gerät zurückgreifen, sowohl bei den Panzern als eben auch bei
anderen äh Fahrzeugen, die holen jetzt irgendwie.
Uraltechnik aus der Sowjetzeit äh aus irgendwelchen Lagern, wo überhaupt nicht klar ist, ob die überhaupt funktionieren, inwiefern die äh überhaupt noch fit gemacht werden können, beziehungsweise wenn sie fit gemacht werden, wie fit sie dann für den kommen bald auch tatsächlich äh sind.
Ja und äh da sie eben auch in der Autoproduktion äh Produktion von so vielen Dingen ähm jetzt hinterherhängen, denke ich mal
in diesem Winter die Situation an der Stelle, was die eigene Produktion betrifft für Russland auch nicht einfacher werden.
Ja ähm mein ich gucke halt mich auch immer.
So was was passiert in in Russland eigentlich? Wie ist die Situation denn in in Russland so für den sag mal normalen Bürger und.
Im Wesentlichen kann man's eigentlich fast zusammenfassen, dass die Situation in Russland erstmal nicht anders ist
als bei uns, nämlich alles ist ein bisschen teurer geworden. So wobei in Russland die Sachen
viele Sachen sich stärker verteuert haben als bei uns oder unterschiedliche Sachen, aber erstmal merken wir alle, nur sowohl in Russland die Leute, als auch hier, dass einfach Dinge teurer werden, so von Zusammenbruch,
so ist jetzt äh.
Kann jetzt weder in Russland die Rede sein noch noch bei uns ja also die Supermärkte sind voll und die Bahnen fahren und es gibt Sprit an den Tankstellen, wenn auch zu ja deutlich erhöhten,
äh Preisen im im Moment, aber ja das Stromnetz ist stabil und das kommt aus der Leitung und eigentlich ist es alles, ich sage mal, alles, außer, dass es halt teurer geworden ist und so ungefähr.
Ist es in Russland im Prinzip,
auch, wobei dort nicht sichtbar ist, dass viele Marken halt verschwunden, sind natürlich IKEA, McDonald's, äh ähm Autos äh gerade sind,
haben sich Autopreise haben sich verdoppelt und Neuwagen sind sind sind kaum äh zu kriegen. Also da,
merkt man's wohl am meisten und auch Lebensmittel sind teurer geworden und Packungsgrößen kleiner und irgendwie Fettanteil in der Butter wurde reduziert und Soja lauter so ist aber kleine Dinge aber ähm.
Ja im Grunde genommen ja plus ein Haufen Leute haben ihre Jobs verloren, aber,
unterm Strich äh so ja es ist äh jetzt ist jetzt nicht schlimm in in Russland,
ja, also nicht nicht schlimmer äh äh nicht schlimmer, schlimmer geworden äh im Vergleich äh zum vornehmen Krieg als als bei uns für
normale Leute, würde ich jetzt äh einfach mal so so einschätzen und äh ja, Russland hat ja auch noch irrsinnig,
Reserven an vor allem irgendwie alter Munition und die die hält sich auch, sodass also meine Schätzungen und und und Berechnungen ja auch.
Von Experten übereinstimmen würde ich eher sagen, dass Russland irgendwie noch
Also das es noch zwei Jahre sind bis hin die Munition ausgeht, aber das andere Ding ist, sie können ja nicht ihre Lager bis irgendwie auf null reduzieren jetzt, weil sie müssen ja noch eigentlich für den Fall, dass dann,
die NATO. Ich meine
ideal wäre natürlich klar, die Russen verfeuern jetzt irgendwie alles, dann geht ihnen komplett die Munition aus und dann brauchen wir nur noch reinzurollen so und sie haben nichts mehr äh äh
aber das wird natürlich nicht passieren so in die Situation werden die sich natürlich nicht bringen und.
Äh Russland kann wahrscheinlich auch gerade für jetzt so einfache Waffen wo sich ja seit 100 Jahren nicht viel geändert hat an der Konstruktion.
Ähm so.
Können die die Produktion wahrscheinlich auch hochfallen. Wir haben Rohstoffe, sie haben die Energie und sie haben wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwo alte Maschinen äh rumstehen. Einzige Probleme sind wahrscheinlich Leute, also Leute zu finden, Mitarbeiter, aber das wird sich.
Also sie können zumindest äh nicht innerhalb von zwei Jahren auch die Produktion so hochfahren, dass es ihnen zumindest an an dummer Munition äh wird's ihnen halt nicht nicht mangeln äh so
äh wahrscheinlich auch an einfachen äh Waffen nicht, aber wie schon richtig sagtest, jetzt,
Präzisions äh Munition oder ganz äh neue Waffen, da könnt's halt schwierig werden, weil einfach,
Russland nicht geschafft hat, eigene Prozessorindustrie äh zu entwickeln hier irgendwie ja äh also gut, aber für manche Waffen reichen auch 20 oder 30 Jahre alte Chips.
Ja nur dass diese Waffen halt nicht für diesen Krieg mehr reichen. So ich meine nicht ohne Grund klopfen sie dann im Iran an und holen sich äh Drohnen
deren Qualität sowohl nicht so zufrieden sind. Das neueste Gerücht ist, dass sie jetzt sogar in Nordkorea anklopfen, um irgendwie Waffen zu bekommen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so
dass sie äh problemlos alles ausrüsten könnten, ne und gerade an so einem Mobilmachung, abgesehen von den politischen Problemen, der das mit sich äh bringt. Das haben wir ja vorhin schon auch wieder diskutiert und früher auch schon mal debattiert.
Es wäre technisch wahrscheinlich einfach überhaupt nicht durchführbar weil sie einfach überhaupt nicht die Ausrüstung haben. Sie haben ja noch nicht mal die Ausrüstung für die Soldaten, die jetzt dort
kämpfen, ja? Denen fehlt.
Alles, den fehlt irgendwie Winterklamotten, denen fehlen Helme, denen fehlen äh äh schusssichere äh Westen, den den den fehlen auch einfach moderne äh Gewehre äh et cetera, Socken.
Und und Hosen.
Und Essen und also alles so, ja? Es ist einfach äh ein ein totales Elend. Gibt dann diverse äh Berichte von Soldaten.
Ja dann äh dort im Einsatz waren jetzt auch Bücher geschrieben haben darüber, ne, also einfach geflohen sind, gesagt haben, ich will mit dem Scheiß nichts mehr zu tun haben, das ist alles äh nicht mehr.
Vertretbar, wenn man sich anhört, was die da für für Storys erzählt haben, wie auch
innerhalb der Armee da miteinander umgegangen wird und was das für ein Hauen und Stechen ist ähm ja also ich weiß nicht ich sehe das nicht, dass sie das alles so konsolidiert bekommen, dass sie in der Lage sind dann auch groß zuzuschlagen.
Ne, wobei wobei man natürlich auch immer aufpassen muss, äh solche, ich sage mal, Berichte, die
auch wenn sie wahr sind und die meisten ich halte sie auch für wahr äh so äh jetzt wirklich zu verallgemeinern äh sind oder für die gesamte Truppe äh gelten, sondern was auch klar geworden ist, ist, dass es da doch
erhebliche Unterschiede äh äh gibt, ja äh und das ist halt viele Truppen gibt, ja wo die Zustände erbärmlich sind, aber es ist nicht so, dass die Russen
jetzt äh dass das russische Militär völlig disfunktional äh wäre, sondern man merkt ja, hat's schon, dass sie auch denken können und sich anpassen und jetzt nicht nicht völlig irrsinnige Dinge.
Tun, also insofern ja äh würde ich eher sagen, wahrscheinlich ein sehr sehr gemischtes äh äh Bild, aber natürlich klar, Motivation, wo soll die herkommen?
Zumal hm es wohl auch aus mir völlig unverständlichen Gründen Probleme gibt mit der Bezahlung, deshalb,
viele Soldaten unzufrieden sind, weil sie die versprochene Zulage nicht kriegen, äh weil wohl teilweise offiziell die,
gar nicht
In der Ukraine im Einsatz sind, sondern laut dann offizieller Militärunterlagen, sagen auf Übung in Russland und deswegen die Leute keine sagen
Kriegszulage äh äh bekommen, weil äh sie offiziell gar nicht da sind, äh wo sie wirklich sind und ähm ja, das hilft natürlich jetzt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt und das das ist das.
Äh kann ich jetzt nun wirklich nicht nachvollziehen, äh dass das ist da dann auch noch am Geld lumpen lassen, weil viele der russischen Soldaten.
Scheinen ja durch Geld motiviert zu sein, was ja alles mehr oder weniger Freiwillige sind. Ähm.
Hat auch damit zu tun, dass du natürlich einen extrem hohen Korruptionsgrad äh hast und dass äh viele dieser Gelder vielleicht durchaus dahinfließen, aber dann eben äh bei irgendwelchen Zwischenstationen
Bei Vorgesetzten äh,
hängen bleiben, die überhaupt nicht auszahlen und äh das äh selber alles einstreichen. Das ist halt das, was ich meine. Also dieses äh.
Die gesamte Korruption des Landes ähm.
Trägt nicht dazu bei, dass dieser ganze Apparat effizient funktioniert.
Ne, effizient nicht, aber.
Was schon interessant sind, also ich habe in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen aktuelle Reiseberichte, so von Reisebloggern, die in äh auch Russland viel unterwegs waren
angeschaut auch in abgelegenen Gegenden und Dörfern und was man sagen muss, aber es ist schon das durchaus die,
Infrastruktur, in,
weiten Teilen äh Russlands sehr ordentlich ist. Ich meine Moskau sowieso, Moskau haben sie halt wirklich schick gemacht.
Vor allem der der Bürgermeister, der auch so ein bisschen als potentieller Nachfolger im Übrigen für Putin gehandelt
äh wird, der halt sich außer Politik sehr großen Politik rausgehalten hat und vor allem nur gesagt hat, hey, wir machen jetzt Moskau schick.
Aber zum Beispiel das das Reisen in russischen Zügen und und so
die sind die sind super, ist ja fast alles irgendwie Nachtzüge mit mit Abteilen und so, die die Züge äh fahren und die Bahnhöfe sind schön renoviert und gestrichen und äh ja also.
Sagen muss, also schon von der so öffentliche Infrastruktur sieht im Großen und Ganzen besser aus,
als sogar in vielen westlichen äh Ländern äh ja äh geschweige denn in der Ukraine oder in ähm,
jetzt Moldawien äh oder oder so, wo ich wo ich das gesehen habe. Also sie da sind da ist Russland hat halt schon man sagen signifikant Geld auch in den letzten zehn Jahren so in in Infrastruktur, in öffentliche Infrastruktur gesteck
das das muss man eben auch sehen und und anerkennen na ja.
Alles anerkennen, aber äh jetzt wo SKF sich auch aus Russland zurückgezogen hat, haben sie halt das Problem, dass sie derzeit noch nicht mal mehr Kugellager für ihre Waggons bekommen und sie sitzen im zunehmenden Maße auch ein Wartungsproblem auf der Schiene haben.
Wenn sich das noch äh versteht, dann geht auch wirklich eine ganz ganz wichtige Infrastruktur verloren, die für äh Russland essenziell ist, insbesondere für die Kriegsführung, ne, weil alles auf Eisenbahn
basiert, ne. Also ich wäre da nicht ganz so optimistisch, aber im Einzelnen kenne ich's natürlich jetzt auch nicht, wie die Situation,
äh ist, es verdichtet sich lediglich, dass einfach die Probleme tendenziell,
größer werden und nicht kleiner. Inwiefern das jetzt Tipping Points auslöst, das muss sich zeigen, nur.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt irgendetwas verbessern würde in Russland
und wenn die wirtschaftliche Aktivität halt noch weiter einbricht, dann wird's äh knifflig, weil nur mit Energie allein kannst du so ein Land halt auch nicht fahren.
Ja also,
Wobei der Weg nach unten ist sehr, sehr lang. Ich meine, bei Nordkorea kann man halt äh so ein bisschen natürlich sehen, wie wie weit nach unten. Es ist gehen kann und wie wie wie
lange äh so was läuft oder oder Venezuela auch, ja, aber,
Ähm ja also da ist Russland in der äh ich sage mal in einer deutlich besseren Verfassung und es ist dann schon erstaunlich, dass trotz der ganzen Korruption äh,
scheint da trotzdem eine ganze Menge Geld an den Stellen angekommen zu sein, auch wo es.
Wofür es gedacht, weil es jedenfalls mein mein Eindruck äh sich bei Straßen, Bau und und öffentlicher Infrastruktur und Regierungsgebäuden und so. Die ist.
Offensichtlich war dann genug Geld da, dass die Leute sich sich da irgendwie
ihren Teil abzwängen und ich meine die die Regel äh für für Korruption und Diebstahl im Putin äh Regime äh lautet ja so äh dass man halt.
Zwar ja stehlen darf, sage ich mal, aber nur von den Richtigen und nicht zu viel als einem rangmäßig zusteht.
Ja, also
äh und das ist halt nicht wirklich genau geregelt, da muss man dann selber so ein bisschen als korrupte Person so ein bisschen Sensibilität und äh beweisen, dass man halt nicht nicht die Hand nicht zu weit aufhält, äh weil.
Dass dann halt ähm dazu führen kann, dass man dann einfach irgendwie verschwindet.
Sehr viel wichtiger noch als die wirtschaftliche Situation in Russland ist die politische Situation in Europa, vielleicht jetzt so zum,
Abschluss der Sendung können wir ja nochmal ein bisschen darüber sinnieren, wie es denn damit so aussieht. Die Befürchtungen sind ja groß, dass durch die Energiekrise und durch ähm sonstige politische Störmanöver äh der Rechten in Europa.
Die ähm doch bisher noch weitgehend ungebrochene Solidarität Europas und der europäischen
mit äh der Ukraine in irgendeiner Form in Gefahr geraten könnte. Ähm
Bisher denke ich, wenn Putin drauf gesetzt hat, dass seine Maßnahmen und insbesondere seinen Versuch hier über äh das Gas für Unruhe zu sorgen, hat es nicht
unbedingt dazu geführt. Man könnte natürlich jetzt argumentieren, dass die Hilfe
europäischen Länder schon immer hätte sehr viel größer sein müssen, als sie es bisher war oder dass sie eben auch noch sehr viel stärker hätte mhm vorgenommen werden müssen von Anfang an. Da bin ich auch ganz mit dabei. Also ich war
Von der Geschwindigkeit, mit der alles angelaufen ist, nicht so begeistert. Andererseits ist der Zug auch jetzt ein wenig ins Rollen gekommen und es ist nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen,
ähm durch ein einzelnes singuläres Wahlereignis oder so äh die Gesamtbewegung ähm,
nachlassen würde. Wie siehst du das?
Ja so ein Ding ist ja ich glaube nicht die nächsten Wahlen sind ja in Italien wo.
Halt aber auch die,
also die die vermutlich stärkste äh ja jetzt rechtspopulistische äh Partei äh deren Führer aber auch äh gesagt hat äh,
na ja ähm selbst wenn wir Italiener jetzt unsere Unterstützung für die Ukraine einstellen würden,
der Rest Europas und die USA nicht die Unterstützung äh für die Ukraine einstellen, aber wir werden
halt äh ja unsere Beziehungen äh äh zu
unseren Bündnispartnern massiv schädigen so und deswegen auch wenn wir irgendwie
nicht die Ukraine nicht unterstützen wollen
äh so. Es gibt halt keine Alternative, ja äh so für einzelne Länder sich da jetzt allzu äh sehr rauszuziehen, ja, sondern
Da ist der Druck einfach extrem äh groß und äh der Preis sagen dann auch für das Ausscheren äh vermutlich ja äh
hoch und äh langfristig äh einfach hoch, wenn da jetzt ein Land sagt.
Also machen wir nicht. So, deswegen ja gebe ich dir völlig recht.
Selbst wenn irgendwie ja es kann sich niemand in Europa,
erstmal so richtig rausziehen oder eine eine Kehrtwende machen und selbst wenn das passiert, würde es wohl am Verlauf nicht viel ändern, weil am Ende ist entscheidend, was die USA.
Tun. So und Europa muss da mitziehen.
Natürlich immer noch die Chance, dass es sich in den USA ändert.
Ja, da stehen jetzt die Midterm Elections äh an im November. Typischerweise.
Gewinnen ja dann immer die anderen so das heißt alle sind bisher davon ausgegangen dass die Republikaner dann sowohl im äh im Haus.
Kongresses als auch äh vielleicht im Senat wieder die Mehrheit übernehmen könnten, das wäre natürlich für die Präsidentschaft von beiden hm.
Suboptimal, allerdings.
Dreht sich da ja auch äh gerade der Wind, wie nachhaltig das ist, wird man dann noch äh sehen müssen, aber der ganze Trump-Skandal, also der eine Millionste Tramskandal, der jetzt da gerade wieder läuft, um diese ganzen geklauten,
Geheimdokumente, der entfacht doch schon eine ganze äh ähm neue Dimension, weil es halt durchaus sein kann, dass Trump ähm.
Tatsächlich jetzt mal angeklagt wird und vielleicht sogar auch verurteilt wird, aber davon abgesehen hat sich einfach ähm.
Der politische Wind ein bisschen gedreht, weil den Amerikanern irgendwie die ganze Nummer wohl dann doch äh ein wenig zu heiß zu sein scheint
derzeit, ja, also da wird äh jetzt geschickt von den Demokraten argumentiert und sozusagen zwischen Republikanern und
mager äh Republikanern unterschieden und äh vielleicht lässt sich hier äh dieser Rollback noch ein wenig Container, das,
Das wird man dann sehen.
Ja, plus ich meine, eine Sache äh.
Die jetzt auch eine Technikalität, die mit diesem zu tun hat. Ähm ist äh das äh.
Mein bisher hat der Präsident immer die Hilfen.
Wurden dann auch immer im Kongress beschlossen so. Jede einzelne, aber hm gleichzeitig autorisiert ihnen der Act.
Per Gesetz quasi auch selber äh die äh Ukraine mit allem unterstützen zu können, was das amerikanische Militär herzugeben hat. Ja das heißt.
Er kann dann zwar vielleicht nicht dem also großzügig Wirtschaftshilfen oder so äh gewähren, aber im Prinzip äh alles, was irgendwie
aus dem aus dem Militärbudget finanziert werden kann und darüber hinaus so kann er dann ohne dass jetzt äh ja das Haus
was er normalerweise die Haushaltshoheit hat oder der Senat, dass die da so ohne weiteres dazwischen funken können. Also selbst für den Fall.
Ähm für den Worst Case würde das jetzt nicht bedeuten äh so, dass da jetzt eine Kehrtwende stattfindet, außer wenn eben Biden oder die Demokraten oder so sich jetzt entscheiden würden zu sagen, nee.
Aber es wird glaube ich in den nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahren äh erstmal nicht der Fall sein oder 20, keine Ahnung, so wie Afghanistan halt auch 20 Jahre gedauert, bis man sich dann überlegt hat.
Das wird uns jetzt teuer.
Zum Abschluss, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit den äh Vorhersagen.
Was solche Kriegssituationen äh betrifft ähm aber wie schon mehrfach.
Angedeutet die nächsten zwei Monate werden auf jeden Fall sehr interessant was die Gegenoffensive der Ukraine betrifft und die weitere Verstärkung.
Dem Zeitpunkt, wo der Winter,
kommt oder der Herbst sich zumindest so breit gemacht hat, dass das schon für nennenswerte äh Änderungen sorgt, dann muss man nochmal evaluieren
Einschätzung von all den Analysten und Experten. Ja, ich meine, man kann ja im Prinzip ja jede Meinung finden, die die einem jetzt gerade so äh passt. Ich versuche mir immer so ein bisschen so einen Mittelwert zu bilden und gewinne so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Es gibt Leute, die halten es vielleicht nicht unbedingt für wahrscheinlich, aber zumindest auch nicht für unmöglich.
Dass die Ukraine noch binnen dieses Jahres ein sich einen Vorteil erarbeiten kann, der langfristig dazu führen kann, dass äh Russland einfach zurück.
Zurückziehen muss.
Andere denken, dass der Konflikt sich auf jeden Fall noch bis ins nächste Jahr ähm deutlich verschieben wird, bevor solche Tendenzen äh absehbar sind.
Ähm dem habe ich wenig hinzuzufügen. Also ich kann da keine eigene Einschätzung abgeben. Das wäre jetzt mal echt sehr äh vermessen.
Ja, also ich fand jetzt für die Frage sagen sowohl im Westen.
Als auch äh in in Russland, insbesondere in Russland herrscht immer noch in den Köpfen.
Vor, so der Gedanke, Russland kann eigentlich nicht verlieren. Ja, es ist also gerade für die Russen
ist es in den Köpfen völlig ausgeschlossen, dass sie gegen ein Land wie die Ukraine,
verlieren könnten. So und auch im Westen in den Köpfen, ich meine, war ja am Anfang gehen ja alle davon aus, so eine Woche, dann ist die Ukraine platt, auch
inzwischen hat man jetzt Hoffnung geschöpft aber in vielen Köpfen ist auch der Gedanke, dass Russland verlieren könnte, so ist irgendwie schwer mit
lang gehegten Überzeugungen zu vereinbaren, so von sagen wir mal Erinnerungen an die alte, große, mächtige Sowjetunion, die irgendwie aber doppelt so viele Leute
äh hatte wie Russland
äh äh heute und irgendwie fünf Mal so starkes äh Militär und so. Das ist irgendwie immer noch in den Köpfen drin und auch wie gesagt auch gerade in in in Russland äh ja herrscht quasi so ein Unbesiegbarkeitsmythos.
Und,
der Krieg wird halt erst dann zu Ende gehen, wenn äh ja auf der einen Seite in Russland äh so vielleicht sich die Überzeugung äh langsam einsickert in die Köpfe, dass man
vielleicht doch verlieren könnte oder am Verlieren ist äh so, das ist quasi eine Sache und im Westen.
Wäre es eben auch wichtig, dass das da in vielen Köpfen dann
ebenfalls die Überzeugung, Einsätze zu sagen, hm ja die Ukraine kann schon gewinnen und auch vielleicht ein bisschen die Angst davor, dass Russland verlieren könnte.
Äh ja ähm so ein bisschen zurückgedrängt wird und dass man der Ukraine dann wirklich auch die schweren Waffen und Waffensysteme
liefert, die es braucht, um dann eben auch militärisch entsprechend Erfolge äh zu erzielen und im Moment geht es ja in die Richtung, aber äh.
Habe nicht das Gefühl, dass wirklich aus sozusagen, dass der Westen irgendwie alles liefert, was er liefern äh äh könnte immer noch nicht so, ja.
Oder auch nicht die Industrie so weit hochfährt wie sie hochfahren äh könnte ja also ein klares Commitment an die Waffenindustrie zu sagen wir produzieren jetzt hier einfach mal für die Ukraine ähm und fahren einfach alles hoch. Das äh hat's ja so auch noch nicht.
Und das das braucht auch immer seine Zeit und äh wie gesagt.
Auch schon erwähnt, im Zweiten Weltkrieg war dann auch oder vor dem zweiten Weltkrieg war dann auch als für die amerikanische Unterstützung an England ging und so, ha, warum liefern wir den Engländer nicht.
Genug Waffen und so und fahren nicht unsere Industrie hoch und das hat dann damals äh alles auch so zwei, drei Jahre gedauert, bis das in in in Gang gekommen.
Ist und das wirklich die Hilfe dann äh wirklich in großen Umfang geflossen ist, wie das hier jetzt sein wird, weiß man nicht.
Aber ähm also.
Meine Sicht auch eben, weil wie gesagt Russland kann sich nicht vorstellen äh zu verlieren. Ähm so und der Westen zögert halt auch äh so ein bisschen mit,
jetzt ja wirklich aus vollen Ohren äh da da in die Ukraine zu unterstützen und ähm.
Und das in Verbindung mit, dass die Ukraine ja sagen dann schon mal einen Nachteil
quasi bevölkerungsmäßig von 1 zu 3 hat, äh der aber ausreichend war, um die Russen zum zum Stehen zu bringen, aber,
um jetzt eben tatsächlich äh diese militärische Stärke.
Aufzubauen, diese Übermacht aufzubauen, die erforderlich wäre, um äh die Russen wirklich aus allen
besetzten Gebieten äh zu vertreiben. Ähm was ja deren Ziel ist, äh so dass sehe ich,
wiederum auch in absehbarer Zeit nicht nicht wirklich. Das heißt, das Beste oder Maximale, worauf die Ukraine hoffen kann, ist eben in der Kerston äh Region.
Erfolgreich zu sein und äh wenn das der Fall ist glaube ich ähm wird es erstmal auch
wahrscheinlich wenig Bewegung geben, weil dann die Fronten erstmal weiter verhärtet äh sein werden und dann ja wird's dann irgendwie weiter in so einen äh Wirtschafts- und
Artilleriekrieg äh äh hineingehen mit unterschiedlicher Intensität
Und ja sich sich eher weiter verfestigen, kann ich mir vorstellen. Dann natürlich mit äh und ähm.
Wovon und im Moment sagen wir mal tickt die Zeit so ein bisschen für die Ukraine.
Aber äh so äh durchaus langfristig jetzt über ein halbes Jahr weg oder so kann's durchaus sein
dass es dann auch den Russen gelingt zumindest
äh ja wieder mehr Zeugs an die an die Front zu zu bringen und auch sich entsprechend anzupassen äh was was hier auch auch auch tun ständig
und das ist halt ja irgendwann schwerer werden wird oder sich die Ukraine immer wieder was Neues einfallen lassen muss, um dann äh.
Weiter weiter vor äh zu schreiten. Also aus meiner Sicht ja äh gibt es derzeit,
ja keinerlei Anzeichen äh äh wirklich, dass das ganze schnell zu Ende gehen könnte.
Sondern sich lange, lange hinziehen wird. Und möglicherweise ja gesagt haben Jahre, mehrere Jahre.
Ja, es ist im Moment meine Einschätzung, aber klar, überraschende Dinge können immer plötzlich passieren und äh bei Russland.
Man nie, da fallen ja halt auch öfter Leute aus Fenstern oder sterben an Herzinfarkten oder Autos explodieren oder andere Dinge.
Passieren äh seltsamer Art und äh ja da können sich natürlich auch Sachen ändern und und wie gesagt, das Einzige, was jetzt
und da sei nicht nicht nicht leichtfertig. Also im Moment ist grad so eine bisschen in der russischen Politik äh so eine so eine
eine größere Unruhephase als eigentlich seit seit Beginn gut. Am Anfang waren sie alle geschockt in den ersten Wochen. Äh.
Dann ja für Putin.
Ist nach wie vor bei der Bevölkerung äh und auch bei den Sicherheitsdiensten und beim Militär und so ist ist eher der der Mann Nummer eins, sitzt also fest im Sattel. Aber.
Es gibt Unzufriedenheit so in.
Allen äh Bereichen, gerade bei den Leuten eben auch im im Apparat. So, die wissen so, die das dies ja plus die Oligarchen äh und so, also sie,
die Leute sind nicht glücklich in in in Russland. Die wissen, was Sache ist. So und äh ja und.
Wohin auch immer, das das das führen mag, aber hm.
Ja, so so eine gewisse so ein gewisses, ich sage mal, Restrisiko oder oder Restwahrscheinlichkeit für überraschende Windung. Es ist auch immer da.
Aber wenn die ausbleibt, wie gesagt, wird uns dieser Krieg erst mal länger erhalten bleiben.
Ich bin zumindest vorsichtig optimistisch, was jetzt diese äh Gegenoffensive ähm betrifft. Ich denke, dass.
Kann durchaus äh eine eine mittlere Wende einleiten und hat es ja auch schon dahingehend getan, als das jetzt überhaupt die Initiative auf Seiten der Ukraine äh liegt und ähm.
Gar nicht so leicht sich ein Szenario auszumalen mit dem Russland, das derzeit militärisch so drehen könnte, also dass,
irgendeiner Form wieder in diese Offensive reinkommen und äh also die Initiative äh und damit in eine Offensive reinkommen.
Ähm und äh von daher ist das so ein bisschen der.
Zahl. Das werden wir jetzt auf jeden Fall weiter beobachten für euch und ich würde sagen, damit haben wir dann erstmal.
Unsere Zusammenfassung der Situation fürs für heute abgeschlossen. Was meinst du?
Ja, ja. Man gibt natürlich unendlich viele Aspekte, aber ich denke, das waren die Dinge, die jetzt gerade so im Vordergrund stehen und.
Insofern machen wir dann äh Schluss für heute. Ich hoffe äh für euch war das äh informativ und ausreichend ausgewogen.
Wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder in den Kommentaren.
Irgendjemand bemängeln wird, dass wir ja nicht genug Belege und Links äh haben werden für all unsere Claims und Beobachtungen.
Ja, nee, haben wir ja auch nicht. Weil es ist mehr so ein Destillat aus vielen.
Ereignissen, Einschätzungen, Kommentaren äh Fonds, Interviews mit mit äh allen möglichen Leuten,
so verinnerlichen wir diesen Konflikt und versuchen von daher hier auch eher so ein bisschen so eine Zusammenfassung all dessen zu geben was so auf uns so einprasselt. Das heißt jetzt nicht das ist gar keine Shownotes gibt, ein paar wird's geben.
Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir immer in der Lage sind, vor allem nicht so einen langen Zeitraum von zwei Monaten jetzt äh komplett wie so ein Logbuch ähm mit einzelnen Links zu äh pflastern, weil manchmal.
Auch bestimmte Berichte oder Einschätzungen oder Beiträge, die man gesehen hat oder auch nur so ein paar Twitter äh Kommentare, später ist wichtig und das dann irgendwie alles noch zusammenzufegen, äh ist gar nicht so einfach.
Mehr Reiseberichte, äh aber zum zum Gasthema, äh wie gesagt, denke ich, wird's ein paar Links geben, wo man sich auch.
Dann regelmäßig selber jeden Tag gucken kann, äh so äh wie sieht's denn aus äh mit dem mit dem Gas und
Wie gesagt, da bin ich auf jeden Fall verhalten optimistisch, was das Gas angeht und halt es auch sogar für möglich, dass Russland einfach die Gaslieferung wieder wieder aufnimmt. Also halte ich für nicht,
ausgeschlossen, dass das dass das passieren äh könnte dann zu aller Überraschung, aber wir werden sehen.
Viele der Quellen nehme ich äh über Twitter wahr. Ich denke, das ist so im Prinzip die mit die beste.
Sekundärquelle, die man so bekommen kann, ja, also wo einfach viele andere Berichte sich manifestieren. Ich habe eine,
Liste, eine Twitterliste zusammengestellt, äh Brit Love äh Slash Ukraine.
Wo ich viele von den Leuten,
die das Geschehen so begleiten und regelmäßig kommentieren und auch zusammenfassung liefern äh auf regelmäßiger Basis ähm eingetragen habe. Also wer Lust hat, sich in diesen
Nachrichtenstrom mal einzuklinken, könnt ihr gerne machen.
Ähm ganz schön viel. Da lese ich auch nicht alles, aber es ist so äh etwas, wo man halt, was ich halt äh.
Immer äh versuche, halbwegs im Blick zu haben, wenn's mal wieder ein definierteres Ereignis äh gibt, was weiß ich, wie diese Bombardierung des.
Russischen Militärflughafens oder jetzt natürlich zuletzt auch Einschätzungen zu dieser Offensive, dann schaue ich da auch äh mal wieder längere Zeit und genauer drauf und äh verbringe schon.
Ein, zwei Stunden pro Tag damit gefühlt ähm von daher war mir der Sache gewogen.
Genau, plus, wie gesagt, dann so die Reiseberichte von, ich sage mal Reisebloggern.
Aus aus Russland äh so wo man dann so ein bisschen sehen kann oder Interviews mit Russen auf der Straße oder oder Ähnliches äh.
Da gibt's ja eine ganze Menge auch die die aus Russland berichten, wo man einfach mal nochmal ein anderes Bild äh äh bekommt oder ein Bild, wie es denn tatsächlich vor Ort.
Aussieht plus was ich noch empfehlen kann, wird es englischen mächtig ist, äh so äh ja,
über die Geschichte von von Nordkorea lohnt sich äh wirklich äh sich das mal mal
anzuschauen, weil da sind viele Dinge äh drin, die man hier in der Schule oder überhaupt in den westlichen Medien gar nicht
so mitbekommen hat, äh wie das denn gelaufen ist, was die meisten kennen, äh Nordkorea nur irgendwie als verarmtes Shithole, aber äh dass das äh tatsächlich mal.
Ja äh das sozialistische Modellland war
und beispielsweise auch ihr paar äh sozusagen Leute aus Japan umgesiedelt sind
äh nach äh Nordkorea, weil die Japaner die Japaner die koreanische Minderheit loswerden wollten und das überhaupt Nordkorea von Japan ursprünglich industrialisiert wurde, als es besetzt
war quasi als Kolonie und so. Alles so Details, äh die man,
nicht präsent hat und ebenso Venezuela. Ich meine, alles nicht mit Russland direkt zu vergleichen,
Aber zeigt halt auch äh ganz gut, wie schnell irgendwo äh.
Äh einen einen Land äh einfach die falsche Abzweigung nehmen kann und und und.
Voll einfach äh in die Katastrophe läuft und das unabhängig davon äh wie,
reich an Rohstoffen äh äh es ist jetzt ist oder äh wie auch immer und äh ja also es kann es kann viel passieren so will ich nur sagen mit mit Russland äh.
Muss aber nicht.
Na ja, also ich denke, es wird noch viel passieren. Wir klinken uns dann wieder ein, wenn genug äh passiert ist und sind dann wieder für ein Update da und äh bis dahin sagen wir tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut, tschau.